[Musique]
Olivier, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bien sûr.
Donc moi je suis chercheur biologiste,
je travaille à Linrae et donc je suis
basé à Normal Sup à Lyon et je suis
aussi directeur de l'Institut Michel
Ser. Je travaille sur les plantes comme
je l'ai pas dit mais je travaille sur le
développement des plantes et à
l'institut Michel Ser on travaille sur
la relation de l'humanité à la nature.
Voilà.
Vous avez fait un petit tour au Japon
quand même ?
J'ai fait oui un petit peu au Japon et
ailleurs. Ouais. Mais bon dit maintenant
je prends plus l'avion hein donc j'ai
quand même beaucoup réduit la voilure.
Mais oui dans mes recherches quand on
est chercheur forcément on va dans des
conférences donc on se balade un peu
quoi.
On a décidé de vous faire venir ce soir
pour parler robustesse et et résilience
pas résilience pardon robustesse des
systèmes et redondance peut-être des
systèmes et et toute cette intrication
de ce concept dans tous les systèmes
auxquels notre société est exposée et
les gens qui peuplent nos sociétés.
Ouais.
Est-ce que vous pouvez résumer ? Je vais
pas dire succintement votre domaine de
recherche, vos anticipations. La
première question que je vous pose,
c'est après résumer en fait d'abord
votre secteur activité et ensuite je
vous poserai la première question.
D'accord. Alors bah donc moi alors sur
la recherche, moi je travaille sur la la
robustesse du vivant et plutôt sous
l'angle biophysique. Donc comment les
plantes utilisent les signaux mécaniques
pour contrôler leur développement, leur
forme. Le genre de question qu'on se
pose, c'est pourquoi les feuilles sont
plates ? Hein ? C'est juste pour dire
donc c'est vraiment de la biophysique de
base et en fait quand on étudie ça bah
assez rapidement on se rend compte que
c'est quelque chose d'émergent donc
c'est la théorie des système complexe
pensées systémiques et tout ça et on se
rend compte qu'il y a plein de choses
contreintuitives. Donc par exemple pour
faire des fleurs qui ont la même taille
sur une plante et ben il vaut mieux que
au niveau cellulaire ce soit très
hétérogène. Alors que on pourrait penser
dans le mode IKEA on va dire que il faut
que ce soit très homogène. Tout le monde
suit la même notice et à la fin ça fait
la même fleur. Bah c'est le contraire
dans le vivant. C'est très hétérogène,
très ératique, on va dire. Et ça produit
de la reproductibilité des formes à la
fin. Et donc cette idée de biologie là,
j'ai fini par en parler en dehors du
labo, notamment auprès des collectivités
territoriales, des entreprises, des
associations parce que derrière il y a
l'idée que pour faire des choses
robustes, donc stables, malgré les
fluctuations, il faut des
contreperformances. En fait, c'est que
le la robustesse, c'est du jeu dans les
rouages, quoi. Et alors, ce qui est très
étonnant, c'est que maintenant, je dis
vraiment très rapidement, maintenant
qu'on rentre dans un monde très
fluctuant et là tous les scientifiques
sont d'accord là-dessus,
instable, voilà, imprévisible, le monde
vuc, voilà, la polycrise, enfin, il y a
plein de mots he pour le dire. Tout le
monde est d'accord hein, le JC, l'IPBS,
enfin tout le monde hein, la CIA,
l'OCDE, le forum économique mondial,
enfin tout le monde est d'accord. Dans
un monde fluctuant, on doit être
robuste.
Vous avez lu le rapport de la CIA ? Oui,
alors en partie B. J'ai pas tout lu,
hein, mais euh c'est y a les scénarios
pour 2035 et cetera, quoi. Ouais. Voilà,
exactement. Donc il il y a plein de
scénarios possibles, mais en fait au
fond si on prend au premier ordre tous
ces rapports, ils disent que quels que
soient les scénarios, ça va tanguer très
fort. Le 21e 21e siècle sera un siècle
fluctuant. Moi j'aime bien le mot
fluctuant parce que ça veut dire
variable et imprévisible.
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez par tanguer
et fluctuant ? Parce que tanguer, ça
fait penser à un petit mal de mer sur la
scène quand on est en train de boire un
petit cocktail
fluctuant. Euh bon, ça bouge un peu.
J'aimerais que vous mettiez un petit peu
d'intensité dans ces mots-là. Pour vous,
vous en vous percevez notre monde
présent comment et comment vous imaginez
notre futur ?
Alors en fait, c'est c'est donc ça
c'était des prédictions il y a 50 ans
hein déjà les fluctuations on savait que
ça allait fluctuer.
Pourquoi vous dites prédictions ?
Euh bah c'est des prédictions parce que
des anticipations.
Ouais. Moi je dirais plutôt des
prédictions des prédictions au sens
systémique quoi. Enfin avec des
modisations informatiques qui disaient
ça allait ça le en gros on est en train
de quitter le monde de la moyenne pour
rentrer dans le monde de l'écart- type.
C'est ça qui se passe. Donc dans un
monde de l'écart-type on on raisonne pas
pareil. Et du coup bah enfin je pense
par rapport au club de Rome qui un
exemple typique en 72 ils avaient prévu
que ça allait tanguer très fort au 21e
siècle. Mais du coup alors qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ? Bah maintenant c'est plus
facile à dire parce queon le vit. En
2021, l'Ouest canadien a eu 50°GR, ça
c'est + 15°gr par rapport à la moyenne
des enfin le max de 35°gr et ça c'était
prévu pour 2100. Quelles sont les
conséquences de tout ça ?
Alors ben alors là dans le cas du
Canada, c'était pas trop grave. Il y a
eu des mégafux mais c'était raisonnable.
le Pakistan 2022. Euh quand on regarde
les images les images satellites hein du
Pakistan 2022, on voit la moitié du pays
qui est tout bleu. Donc là, c'est des
vraiment des méga inondations mais de
taille du pays quoi. Alors là, c'est
c'est des millions euh de personnes qui
sont déplacées, des écoles détruites,
des ponts détruits et cetera. Donc c'est
ça le monde fluctuant. C'est des remous
sociaux, c'est des crises géopolitiques.
Non, c'est tout connecté he évidemment.
C'est des famines,
c'est des famines, c'est des épidémies,
enfin c'est tout tout le bazar quoi.
Perturbation de chaîne logistique.
Exactement. Voilà. Bah d'ailleurs et
alors c'est ça aussi on le voit hein le
canal de Suè qui s'est fait bloquer par
un porte conteneur c'est totalement
anecdotique mais ça révèle la fragilité
du système. Crot Strike en le 19 juillet
dernier pas pan pas informatique mondial
pareil que un monopole d'une une boîte
qui fait la cybersécurité pour les
systèmes Windows extrêmement fragile. En
fait on a pensé les systèmes sous le
compas de la performance efficacité
efficience concentration centralisation
et surtout en fait c'est même pire que
ça hein. Et donc vraiment la
performance, moi je je la définis comme
un contrôleur de gestion, la somme de
l'efficacité et de l'efficience
atteindre son objectif avec le moins de
moyen possible. Donc c'est de
l'optimisation vraiment forçonnée et du
coup qui canalise au sens littéraire du
terme. Donc le canal de Suè c'est
vraiment l'image parfaite pour le monde
de la performance.
Alors on va faire passer présent futur.
Ouais
passé. Qu'est-ce qui nous a mené à ça ?
De l'optimisation de la performance.
Ouais. Alors, si on remonte très loin,
hein, je vais remonter très loin et
c'est presque un peu dommage parce que
ça peut nous excuser de ce qu'on fait
plus récemment, mais pour moi ça démarre
au néolithique, c'est qu'en fait quand
les humains commencent à faire de
l'agriculture, ils s'édentarisent, il
domestiquent, en fait, ils décident de
contrôler la nature. En fait, ils
sécurisent leur prise alimentaire. Et
donc, quand on fait ça, en fait, on se
met dans un climat d'abondance
matérielle, abondance de biomasse,
abondance d'aliments local, hein. Alors,
une fois qu'on fait ça, alors ça c'est
le biologiste qui parle là. Si on met
des êtres vivants, alors je biologise un
peu trop là mais c'est juste pour c'est
un regard. Si on met des êtres vivants
dans un monde d'abondance matériel, ils
font de la compétition et de la
performance. À partir de là, s'ils font
de la compétition de la performance et
ben ils vont faire encore plus d'impact
sur l'environnement. Donc du coup bah
c'est la colonisation, les plantations à
la renaissance, la mécanisation dans la
révolution industrielle et depuis les
années 50 c'est le pétrole, le numérique
et donc là on part en exponentiel et
donc en fait on est c'est la grande
accélération hein de Will Stephen. Donc
on est on est vraiment là-dedans et du
coup ben aujourd'hui le système se casse
en fait c'est terminé le monde de la
performance se termine en fait et donc
comment ça se matérialise ? Ah ben on le
voit en fait hein. Donc c'est alors je
vais pas reprendre le can le 16 mais
Everg boîte de construction chinoise qui
est en train de se casser la figure.
Boeing qui a des difficultés enfin les
gros hein ils commencent à sentir des
failles. Les petits aussi hein bien sûr
mais on entend moins parler quoi. Mais
les gros et puis il y a aussi autre
chose c'est les ultra performants. Donc
Elon Musk, Jeff Bezos, Samaltman et les
autres hein. Il y en a plein d'autres.
Je prends beaucoup de
Bruno. Oui. Alors il ou dans un autre
style mais je prends les les performants
qui ont beaucoup d'argent parce que
c'est plus visible. c'est qu'en fait ils
sont euh ils sont dans un délire de la
performance. Là, on est sorti du culte
de la performance pour aller dans un
délire de la performance. Donc euh Elon
Moss qui veut aller sur Mars euh bah
c'est du délire, c'est un projet de mort
hein. Aurélien Barreau dirait mieux que
moi, hein. C'est en fait c'est aller sur
une projet de mort
parce que alors c'est tout simple, c'est
pour une raison agricole hein. Donc là,
je vais mettre ma casquette Inra là. Euh
en fait sur Mars et sur n'importe quelle
autre planète et même sur Terre, on ne
sait pas faire l'agriculture circulaire.
Donc si dans cette pièce je mets du sol,
de l'eau, des plantes et que j'espère
nourrir des cosmonautes pendant des
années avec ça et ben c'est pas
possible. En fait, il y a toujours une
bactérie, un champignon qui va faire
dériver tout le système et à la fin soit
il y aura plus qu'une plante, soit que
enfin donc ça ne va pas marcher.
Est-ce que vous connaissez ? Je demande
à me faire fax checker. Ça ça s'appelle
le syndrome de l'île déserte.
OK. Vous
vous retrouvez sur une île déserte parce
que vous êtes naufragé. Vous avez deux
choix.
Soit vous mangez toutes les noixs de
coco
et vous crevez.
Mais ça prendra un peu plus de temps que
si vous coupez tous les arbres, vous
faites un radeau, vous prenez toutes les
noix de coco et vous essayez de chercher
un autre une autre terre promise.
Est-ce que vous pensez pas que la
démarche des lieux de musque,
c'est une démarche d'aller chercher une
nouvelle terre promise ? sous prétexte
d'aller sur Mars, c'est de faire rêver
les gens, d'aller chercher une nouvelle
technologie et ensuite au lieu d'aller
sur Mars
faire de la mise en orbitation
d'astéroïdes pour faire de
l'exploitation
autour de la Terre et potentiellement
développer nos technologies qui
pourraient nous affranchir
de notre petite planète bleue.
Alors sur
c'est du technolutionniste.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Le le là, je renvoie
encore au rapport MDOS qui est quand
même fondateur là-dessus dans le dans
les 12 scénarios du rapport MDOS de 72,
il y en a un où on a accès à de
nouvelles ressources et donc alors le
rapport Mdose, le scénario standard,
c'est une cour en cloche hein, donc on
bascule quoi. Le scénario avec l'accès
aux ressources comme ça des au fond des
océans dans les astéroïdes ou je sais
pas où, ça ne change absolument rien à
la trajectoire, ça fait juste plus de
pollution. Donc c'est c'est vraiment un
scénario qui n'a vraiment aucun sens.
C'est-à-dire que c'est importer la mort
sur la planète enfin sur la planète
Terre. Donc du coup le vraiment le
projet de d'aller sur Mars
symboliquement c'est un projet de mort.
Mais en fait il y a pas que lui hein.
Donc aller sur Mars, c'est la mort.
Faire des bunkers en Nouvelle-Zélande
bah c'est des tombeaux hein. Donc c'est
un projet de mort aussi. MS qui veut
faire une ville né en plein désert
saoudien c'est une ville morte. Enfin
les ultra performants ont des projets de
mort. Donc ça c'est un signe du champ du
signe. Alors c'est pas le signe noir là
mais c'est le champ du signe. Donc en
fait on est à la les quand les ultra
performants sont à ce point-là délirant.
Alors ils vont embarquer beaucoup de
gens avec eux. C'est ça qui m'inquiète.
C'est qu' il risque d'y avoir beaucoup
de casse parce qu'ils vont faire rêver
les gens dans ce cauchemar finalement.
Mais ça te dit aussi que c'est la fin.
On pourra pas être plus délirant que ça
quoi.
C'est c'est pour vous une façon en fait
de se donner de l'espoir alors que on
sait pertinemment qu'on marche sur la
tête.
Alors c'est pas je peux alors peut-être
que je me donne un peu d'espoir, ça je
c'est possible mais je crois vraiment
que c'est la fin de ce système. On peut
on peut enf même il y a un autre exemple
he les les fameuses 500 plus grandes
fortunes françaises he qui en 10 ans ont
accumulé 1000 milliards d'euros. Donc
elles ont fait x 5 en disant bon ça fait
un/ers de la dette nationale française.
Bon on sait qu'ils vont pas faire x 5
les 10 prochaines années. C'est
physiquement impossible hein. Donc c'est
on sait que ça on arrive à la fin là on
arrive à au moment au moment du
basculement hein. C'est c'est enfin
c'est tous les jours plus véridiqu
et donc quand ça bascule ça fait quoi ?
Alors est-ce que c'est long long et
douloureux
ou est-ce que c'est c'est d'un coup ?
Alors le le pour moi le basculement
alors c'est là aussi le biologiste hein
c'est euh en fait
le changement de phase.
Ouais. Le changement de phase. En fait
moi j'aime bien les l'analogie du vivant
pour ça. Le une nuée d'oiseaux euh une
nuée d'oiseaux euh elle bascule aussi
hein. Elle tourne à droite, elle tourne
à gauche quoi. Comment fait-elle pour
basculer de droite à gauche ? Alors
c'est très simple. Ce sont toujours les
oiseaux à la périphérie du groupe qui
guident le groupe. Parce que les oiseaux
à la périphérie du groupe, ils sont
exposés aux fluctuations du monde. Les
oiseaux qui sont au cœur du système sont
aveugles au monde. Ils ne voient rien.
Ils voient que les oiseaux voisins. Donc
du coup bah ce qui se passe c'est que
quand ça bascule en fait ce sont les
oiseaux à la périphérie qui font
basculer tout le système. Il y a la
phrase de Jean-Luc Godard hein. C'est la
marche qui tient la page. C'est la marge
qui tient la page. Ça c'est puant. Oui.
Ben non, ça c'est la marge. C'est la
marge. Et en fait c'est c'est ça qui ex
tous les systèmes basculent par les
marges.
Quelle est notre relure de système ?
Le notre
notre relure.
Notre rele. Bah oui. Bah c'est oui.
Alors notre relure bah c'est en fait
c'est les marges. C'est que en fait il y
a un moment où les marges se parlent.
C'est là qu'elles se parlent en fait.
C'est euh euh et donc en fait tous les
tous les projets là qui sont euh
marginaux euh dans le sens mais ça au
sens large hein, c'est l'agroécologie,
le taux réparable, les conventions
citoyennes, tout ça, ça c'est plutôt au
marge hein de du cœur du système. Et ben
en fait ça à un moment ça clique parce
que quand on rentre dans des fortes
fluctuations, c'est eux qu'on va voir
parce qu'ils sont déjà exposés aux
fluctuations, ils ont déjà en fait mis
en place des solutions robustes et donc
en fait ils sont en avance sur le
basculement. Et donc un basculement pour
répondre à la question comment ça se
passe ? et ben c'est les marches qui
contaminent le cœur. Donc en fait si on
veut voir le monde d'après, il faut pas
regarder Total Minze tout ça. Là ça
c'est le monde faisander de la
performance d'avant. Fais ça n'engage
que vous he
Oui bien sûr. Ah mais oui bien sûr. Mais
dans chez Total il y a des marges aussi
c'est que dans chez Total il y a
certainement des gens qui pensent au
futur de Total Minze je suis sûr qu'il y
a aussi des des sous-groupes qui sont en
train de repenser leur système
pour faire du nucléaire. Alors alors
sur nucléaire, il y a des choses à dire
aussi sur le nucléaire mais pour le
basculement c'est une contamination et
du coup ça veut dire qu'il y aura de la
casse he faut pas arriver, il y a déjà
de la casse on va dire mais c'est
graduel. Alors
ça veut dire quoi mass inerciel ?
Mass inerciel. Alors pourquoi ? Pour
juste pour savoir pour faire bouger le
bateau.
Ah oui la masse inert. Bah euh alors il
y a il y a il y a il y a des chiffres
hein là-dessus hein. Il y a le fameux
3,5 % là. Enfin ça c'est les minorités
actives. Donc c'est la masse critique
pour faire basculer un Titanic hein.
C'est ça. Donc c'est ça a été euh étudié
pour euh les révolutions du 20e siècle.
Donc combien de gens euh il faut qu'ent
r ça ça bascule ?
Donc ça veut dire que c'est pas du tout
linéaire ce truclin. C'est en fait c'est
à une toute peur. Donc en France c'est 2
millions de personnes. 2 millions de
personnes dans la rue et le système
bascule. Donc en fait c'est pas que
c'est
les écologistes, ils ont fait combien de
pourcent aux élections ?
Euh bah un peu plus que ça. Ouai. Donc
ça change pas.
Oui bien sûr mais ils sont pas dans la
rue. C'est c'est la différence he c'est
3,5 % dans la rue. Donc par exemple la
réforme des retraites c'était moins.
Mais ça commence c'était 1,2 million
hein. Donc c'est maximum hein. Donc ça
veut dire qu'on commence à sera les
gilets jaunes c'était aussi plus loin.
Donc en fait on est dans un climat
préinsurrectionnel
assez clairement et donc en fait à la
prochaine fluctuation c'est possible
qu'il y ait un un basculement. Alors, je
je suis pas en train de d'espérer le
grand soir, hein, euh parce qu'il y il y
a pas de de célébration à faire. C'est
juste que c'est euh presque
thermodynamique. On arrive à un moment
euh on est au seuil du basculement et il
y a des signaux faibles absolument
partout pour le dire.
On dit pas on dit plus d'ailleurs des
signaux faibles.
Ouais, c'est des signaux en fait.
Des signaux précurseurs
ou précurseurs. D'accord. Ils sont Oui,
parce qu'ils sont forts mais ils sont là
en fait, ils sont partout quoi. H
Donc, le présent c'est ça. Le futur vous
le voyez comment ? Autrement que
changement de phase. C'est concrètement
c'estd que j'ai écouté beaucoup de vos
conférences.
Ouais.
Ça ça ressemblait un peu avec tout le
respect que je vous dois un peu une
carmè d'écologiste où on vendait des
chouchous. C'estàd que tout le monde
connaît le problème. On est tous
ensemble pour se rassurer. Bon on essaie
d'essimer mais comme c'est pas très sexy
et que c'est donc ça fait pas
grand-chose et puis bon comment vous le
voyez clair.
Ouais ouais je je suis un peu plus
optimiste.
Qui vous a dit que j'étais pas optimiste
? Bien sûr, sûr, mais enf en tout cas
par rapport à cette lecture là quoi. Moi
moi il me semble que en fait quand on
passe du temps avec les marges justement
hein, donc agroécologie, le réparable,
tout ça et ben on se rend compte queil y
a des gens qui sont très joyeux parce
qu'en fait ils sont ils sont en train de
construire le monde d'après. C'est qu'en
fait ils sont en train de construire un
monde qui sera capable de passer le
moment du basculement parce que si on
est robuste, on est aussi robuste à la
période du basculement et en plus on
construit le monde d'après. Mais par
contre les fluctuations faut bien
considérer que c'est on en a pour deux
siècles. C'est pas des fluctuations
enfin les fluctuations qu'on est en
train de générer là ça va pas se réparer
en 20 ans. C'est on a dégradé
l'environnement à une vitesse qui est
incroyable. Enfin juste pour donner un
chiffre he quand même. En donc c'est le
fameux chiffre en 30 ans, on a perdu 80
% des insectes en masse. Donc on
pourrait se dire bon bah ça c'est déjà
arrivé. Alors en fait on n pas d'exemple
dans toute l'histoire de la terre d'une
extinction aussi rapide. L'image qu'on a
c'est les dinosaures. He le le truc
hollywoodien. Voilà. Bah ouais, c'est
30000 ans, 33000 ans et c'est après la
météorite. C'est qu'avant la météorite,
ça faisait déjà 300000 ans qu'ils
étaient en déclin. La météorite est
tombée et après il a fallu 33000 ans
pour qu'il disparaisse. Donc en fait ça
c'est brutal au niveau géologique. Donc
ce qui se passe actuellement, il y a pas
d'adjectif pour l'expliquer.
Formidable. Si.
Oui, formidable. Oui, voilà. Redoutable.
Ouais. Non, mais formidable de
formidaux.
Oui, bien sûr. Oui. Bah redoutable. Oui,
exactement.
Pas de redoutable, de terrifiant.
Oui, d'accord. Terrifiant. Oui. Bah oui,
bien sûr. Non, mais ça ça peut alors ça
peut ça peut sidérer mais en fait faut
juste comprendre en fait là c'est là où
je suis bêtement scientifique. Quand on
endosse le fait scientifique, on sait
que ça va tanguer pour le 21e siècle et
pour le 22e siècle. C'est inévitable. En
fait, pendant très longtemps, ben les
années 80, on parlait de développement
durable, on disait on se souciait de
l'impact de nos activités sur
l'environnement. Ben maintenant, il faut
changer le logiciel, faut se soucier de
l'impact de l'environnement sur nos
activités. Donc ça change tout. c'est
qu'en fait c'est plus on n'est plus dans
une posture descendante sur
l'environnement. C'est les fluctuations
de l'environnement qui vont décider de
ce qu'on peut faire et de ce qu'on ne
peut pas faire.
Est-ce qu'on a pas passé un point de non
retour quand je vous décris le système ?
Ouais. Ouais.
Bon alors l'école de Chicago à fond à
fond à fond en prenant des toxiques pour
pouvoir tenir le choc. On continue, on
continue. On on a considéré que nos
élèves ingénieurs, on devait les élever
comme dans une industrie, c'est-à-dire
non pas créer des cerveaux mais créer
des outils.
On se retrouve avec une mentalité à
changer. Il faudra une deux générations,
donc 30 ans. H
c'est un énorme bateau. C'est une
intrication des systèmes qui est ultra
profonde.
Ouais, ça c'est vrai.
Le, je prends un exemple, les Français
payent la retraite des Américains avec X
Y fond ou XY bijoux de famille vendu ou
XY comportement de guerre économique.
Donc ce système ultra intriqué qui a une
prédation sur le biotop où c'est le
biotop qui en fait paye
le en beaucoup plus en dividende aux
actionnaires que le propre argent et
ce système ce mamouth
Ouais. avec des petits oiseaux écolos en
marge ou des petits oiseaux qui essayent
d'être plus robuste en marge.
Ouais,
ils vont jamais réussir à faire bouger
le système.
Ah oui, mais le système il va se raer en
fait. Ce qui fait qu'un que en fait ce
qu'on ce qu'on quand je parle des nué
d'oiseaux là, quand je dis que c'est les
marges qui font basculer le système, bah
le un système bascule en multipliant les
marges. Et donc c'est le nombre
d'interstices qui fait que ça que ça
bascule. Et donc un les gros mammouthes
vont se fragmenter forcément. Enfin, il
y a pas le choix. Et et du coup quand il
y a beaucoup plus de marge, il y a
beaucoup plus de la contamination se
démultiplie. Et donc pour moi le le
basculement, il va se faire par
fragmentation.
Mais c'est mais ça peut être une
fragmentation positive hein. C'est c'est
pas la parce que la fragmentation ça
peut faire penser voilà le le repli sur
soi ou je sais pas, il y aura de ça
aussi hein. Évidemment, ça
fait penser à l'accident de la route.
Ou accident de la route. OK. Ou voilà.
Non, mais mais par exemple, des grands
consortiums ne vont plus tenir la route
évidemment hein, c'est beaucoup trop
fragile. Euh donc, ils vont forcément
euh se fragmenter quoi. Et donc, il y
aura plus de marge et donc plus de
contamination vers le cœur, vers le
système robuste. Il y aura pas le choix
hein euh dans un système fluctuant, il
faut être robuste.
Ça va pas terminer au plugil là ça ?
Alors, il y aura bah enfin alors je
encore je suis pas devin hein, mais mais
euh il y a une période compliquée,
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait quand euh et ça
on le voit bien dans les systèmes
vivants euh quand on est dans en
abondance et qu'on passe dans la pénurie
euh il y a un moment où euh en fait on
est on a encore le logiciel de
l'abondance, donc on fait de la
compétition de la performance alors
qu'on est déjà dans la pénurie. Alors
là, c'est pire que tout parce queon
accélère la pénurie, fait la dette.
On fait de la dette. Voilà, par exemple,
ouais. Non mais on est exactement
làdedans. Mais en fait ce qui ce qui
vient après par contre c'est une fois
qu'on a compris que c'était fluctuant et
cetera, bah en fait on on fait des
stratégies robustes. On on passe de
l'abondance matérielle à l'abondance des
interactions, richesses des
interactions. Moi, c'est ce que je dis
aux jeunes que je rencontre he le le
monde qui vient pour moi, il est très
positif. C'est le monde le monde de la
performance, c'est un c'est le monde de
l'autoroute. C'est ça. Efficacité,
efficience, c'est l'autoroute. On
rencontre personne sur une autoroute.
Qui veut vivre sur une autoroute ? C'est
c'est vraiment c'est stérile quoi. Alors
qu'en fait bah c'est le chemin de
campagne quoi, le chemin de traverse
quoi. Alors c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être très bucolique hein de le dire
comme ça mais donc ça veut dire que
c'est plus compliqué, c'est plus lent,
il y a des il y a des cailloux dans la
chaussure et cetera, mais c'est plus
riche, on rencontre plus de monde quoi.
C'est c'est quand même on sent plus
vivant quoi.
Philosophiquement ça pourrait se résumer
comment
philosophiquement alors je il y a plein
de choses hein.
Important c'est pas la destination,
c'est le chemin
par exemple. Voilà, c'est ça. C'est un
peu taoïste. Enfin, c'est il y a des il
y a des tas de choses mais enfin là je
je suis pas philosophe donc je vais pas
faire tout un mais en effet c'est une
philosophie de vie hein. C'est en fait
c'est c'est je peux dire comme ça c'est
on dit que en fait dans le dans le monde
actuel on manque de temps et donc le
piège performant c'est quand on manque
de temps c'est d'accélérer. Donc si on
accélère là on va dans le mur en
claxonnant quand on manque de temps en
fait faut juste réaliser qu'on évolue
dans un espace à quatre dimensions. Les
trois dimensions du temps. la 4è
dimension de l'espace de du de trois
dimensions de l'espace, c'est la 4è
dimension du temps. Donc si on manque de
temps, il nous reste les trois
dimensions de l'espace. Donc on va se
reconnecter à l'espace. Je reprends
l'agroécologie, c'est exactement ça.
C'est se reconnecter à l'espace. Et donc
en fait le le monde robuste qui vient,
on pourrait l'appeler comme ça, ça sera
un monde interconnecté avec son
territoire forcément et des territoires
interconnectés entre eux. C'est pas du
repli sur soi sur dualiste, c'est c'est
encore autre chose quoi.
Dans un monde mondialisé.
Ouais. Euh comment vous analysez, quelle
est votre lecture sur les différents
conflits qui sont en train de nous péter
à la tête ?
Alors, je suis pas géopolitologue he je
dois le dire tout de suite. Je ne suis
qu'un biologiste, mais bah on voit bien
qu'il y a des tas de liens aux
ressources dans dans tous ces conflits,
hein. Soit d'ailleurs, parfois par
l'abondance de ressources qui permet de
partir dans la compétition, la
performance, hein, faut bien comprendre
que pour faire la guerre, faut des sous,
faut de l'argent, donc faut des
ressources. Donc en fait, quand on n pas
de ressources, on ne fait pas la guerre.
C'est c'est juste pas possible. Là, je
vous renvoie à George Bataille, la part
Maudite, pour moi un vraiment un livre à
lire 1949 mais d'une modernité
incroyable. Euh et ben ça en fait ça
éclaire vraiment beaucoup sur euh la
géopolitique mondiale quoi. Le lien aux
ressources c'est euh c'est assez clair.
Et après, il y a d'autres évidemment il
y a d'autres raisons. Euh les justement
les points de bascule la Syrie euh quand
il y a eu des sécheresses après les
paysans qui partent de leur zone parce
qu'on leur a demandé de faire du coton
euh en période de sécheresse par c'est
vraiment le truc complètement délirant
qu'ils sont venus en ville et ils sont
ils sont pas contents quoi. Donc voilà
rébellion et cetera c'est un des
facteurs. C'est pas le seul facteur mais
c'est un des facteurs qui explique ça.
Donc le lien aux ressources il est il
est partout hein. Il il est pluriel mais
sur le lien oui quand même sur le lien
ressources alors je vais changer de la
géopolitique à des projets
scientifiques.
Par exemple le projet ITER de fusion
nucléaire c'est quoi l'objectif
exactement de la fusion nucléaire ?
C'est d'avoir de l'énergie gratuite et
illimitée avec de l'eau.
Continuons gment.
Mais ça c'est si ça arrive c'est la
guerre éternelle. Il faut surtout pas
que le projet ITER réussisse. Il faut
que ce soit un échec parce que si ça
marche alors là c'est la guerre
permanente.
Ça fonctionne.
Ça fonctionne exactement. Si vraiment on
arrive à avoir de la de l'énergie
gratuite, on va faire la guerre jusqu'à
la fin de de des vies enf des humains,
quoi. Donc il faut surtout pas que ça
marche. Et je suis très étonné que dans
le monde scientifique, on on se pose pas
ces questions de base quoi. Enfin,
George Bataille quoi. Euh
vous êtes étonné dans le monde que le
monde scientifique se pose pas ce type
de de d'extrapolation et de projection.
Ouais,
on va dire bon des chercheurs qui
cherchent, il y en a beaucoup puis bon,
on va dire on s'en fout.
On s'en fout,
je comprends.
Mais les politiques,
Ouais.
quand le monde scientifique s'adresse à
eux,
ouais,
ils vous écoutent. Ah bah c'est de
notoriété publique que on n'est pas très
très écouté hein. Alors en fait j'aurais
pas dire ça les politiques locaux oui
hein parce que eux justement bah ils
sont au marge ils sont exposés aux
fluctuation ils restent dans le
territoire et du coup bah donc moi je
suis à Lyon la mairie de Lyon la
métropole Ville urbane tout ça le les
équipes municipales nous écoutent hein
enfin en tout cas quand on leur parle de
robustess parle hein. Ils ont créé même
des jeux tumultes là voilà pourer le
monde fluctuant. Enfin, il se passe des
choses. Contrat de santé, santé commune
avec la santé étendue au non humain.
Enfin, je veux dire, c'est il se passe
des choses. Par contre, au niveau
national euh enfin moi, j'ai déjà
rencontré quelques politiques nationaux.
Alors, euh, ouais, je
juste leur fonction.
Ouais. Commissariat au plan par exemple.
Euh
vous avez rencontré François ?
Non, alors pas François, je peut-être
pas lire. Mais en fait, ce que ce qu'on
ce qu'on enfin ce qu'on voit en fait
dans ces interactions, mais en fait,
c'est qu'il y a un tableur Excel entre
nous. c'est que un scientifique qui
parle à à un politique nationale, hein,
il y a un tableur Excel et on voit très
bien qu'il y a la balance commerciale
entre nous deux quoi. Et du coup, en
fait, on peut dire ce qu'on veut. Euh si
ça ne n'ége pas sur recettes et dépenses
nationales, en fait, on sera pas
entendu. Alors ce ce qui est vraiment
dommage hein parce que on on fabrique
des choses quoi. Enfin, je pense qu'on
par rapport à Makinz, on a des choses à
dire hein quand même hein. Enfin, on
peut produire des indicateurs des une
pensée quoi. Et bon, malheureusement,
enfin, je fais un peu du politique
bashing là, mais pour l'instant, en tout
cas la situation actuelle, on n'est pas
écouté très clairement.
Quand vous allez les voir, vous leur
fournissez préconisation
ou vous c'est quelle est votre stratégie
pour s'adresser à eux ? Vous leur faites
peur, vous leur faites pas peur ?
Vous leur fournissez des patchs, pas de
patch.
Bah c'est de l'éducation hein, déjà.
Enfin, c'est c'est notre rôle quoi.
Enfin, le le chercheur ne doit pas
décider hein, c'est juste un quelqu'un
qui doit éclairer. Donc, on n'est pas là
pourcier, on n'est pas légitime pour
décider. On est juste là pour donner euh
le le fait scientifique. Mais par
contre, ce que je note euh c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de mécanisme politique pour
endosser le fait scientifique. Le JC a
des mécanismes pour endosser le fit
scientifique. C'est même le principe du
JC, c'est on endosse le fit
scientifique. Bah le gouvernement et
puis pas que le français hein, à peu
près tous les gouvernants n'ont pas de
mécanisme pour endosser le fait
scientifique. Donc ça veut dire qu'on
peut on met une opinion ou un fait
scientifique, c'est au même niveau quoi.
Et ça c'est très problématique quand
même. Alors il y a des commissions
parlementaires qui font un vrai travail
hein. C'est ça qui est terrible en plus,
c'est qu'il y a des commissions qui font
des super rapports avec des enfin là
pour le coup ça endose plutôt le
scientifique mais après ça s'arrête ça
ça va pas plus loin quoi. Donc voilà du
coup bon bah c'est c'est donc c'est un
peu désespérant mais ça veut peut-être
dire aussi qu'il faut trouver d'autres
moyens. Donc la convention citoyenne
pour le climat par exemple je trouvais
que ça c'était très intéressant comme
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui a
inspiré de Gmil en Belgique hein. Donc
c'est ça vient pas de nous ils sont très
bien. Ou je suis très fan la Wallony
Bruxelles c'est vraiment
petits oiseaux. Non mais en fait ils
vivent ils sont déjà dans un monde très
perturbé hein. Ils sont ils sont quand
même pris des sacrés crises dans ces
dernières décennies et du coup ils ont
inventé un monde un peu plus ératique,
un peu plus Gaston la gaffe quoi. Et
non pas Gaston la gaffe.
Ouais si quand même un peu les Wilons à
Bruxelles, ils sont trop sympas. Ouais
Gaston la gaffe il est super sympa. Bah
moi c'est mon philosophe hein. Si je
devrais en avoir un, ça serait gaston la
gaffe quoi. Mais mais du coup ouais bah
voilà en Belgique, il développe des
choses intéressantes quoi. Et justement
j'ai mis donc la convention citoyenne
c'est le principe hein, c'est celle
qu'on a fait en France, c'est de prendre
150 citoyens tirés au sort dedans il y a
des climatoques. Tout ça pour travailler
sur le climat. Je trou génial quoi. Et
en fait ce que ça ce que ça produit 149
propositions plus ambitieuses que ce
qu'auraient fait les députés, plus
légitimes que ce qu'auraient fait les
experts et approuvé à 96 % par les par
les 150 citoyens. Donc ça c'est
extrêmement positif. Donc ça c'est
vraiment de la puissance. Donc ça se
propage, ça se déploie. Voilà, c'est
quelque chose qui dépasse, une question
qui dépasse ben du coup on a un
protocole qui dépasse. Mais bon,
évidemment là, on s'est retrouvé avec un
président qui était lui dans le pouvoir
et donc qui a stérilisé ça quoi, qui a
dit ça, je prends, ça je prends pas. Et
donc là, bon ben c'est un ratage enfin
c'est du gâchi quoi. C'était un moment
pour Emmanuel Macron pour qu'il rentre
dans l'histoire quand même. Et bah il a
décidé de ne pas rentrer dans
l'histoire.
Vous vouliez faire rentrer Emmanuel
Macron dans l'histoire ?
Non, je voulais pas mais c'est c'est
aujourd'hui c'est très facile de rentrer
dans l'histoire. On est dans un monde
exceptionnel. On est dans une période
exceptionnelle. En 2050, on est à peu
près sûr que l'humanité va réduire en
population mondiale tous les ans.
De combien ? Alors ça je sais pas mais
c'est ça ça sera la courbe quoi. Et
c'est pour des raisons économiques en
plus hein. Donc ça veut dire que en 2050
euh on va euh en fait enfin les humains
homo sapiens hein en 315000 ans d'homo
sapiens ce sera la première fois que la
population mondiale humaine va baisser.
On va vivre ça. On est dans un moment
exceptionnel. Et donc euh si on on a les
signaux là précurseurs et qu'on les
voit, c'est quand même très facile de
voir le monde qui bascule quoi. Et donc
de rentrer dans l'histoire. Donc en
fait, je pensais que quand on est un
personnel politique, c'était un des
objets quand même hein. Bah là
manifestement non quoi.
Vous êtes pur.
L'objectif des politiques c'est
simplement de prolonger les courbes.
Oui, bien sûr. Non, mais il y a un côté
conservateur par défaut, quoi. Les
chercheurs aussi sont très
conservateurs, hein. Enfin, faut pas non
plus voilà, on est on est un peu tous,
c'est le confort hein du conservatisme.
Mais mais là, on vit un moment
exceptionnel. Il y a quand même en
général dans les moments exceptionnels,
il y a des personnes qui se révèlent
quoi et qui d'un seul coup changent
changent l'histoire quoi. Bon là pour
l'instant bon ils sont pas là quoi.
Est-ce que vous avez étudié
l'effondrement de l'exunion soviétique ?
Alors je l'ai pas étudié, je l'ai vu
mais je l'ai pas étudié. Non.
Qu'est-ce qui a permis à à l'exunion
soviétique qui est maintenant la Russie
de pas s'effondrer ?
Ah bah il y a une forme de robustesse
culturelle hein en en URSS ou en Russie
actuelle. En fait, c'est d'ailleurs
c'est très étonnant, c'est que je
parlais de pouvoir et puissance. Euh
Poutine est dans le pouvoir, son peuple
est dans la puissance. C'est incroyable
parce que Poutine, il est euh en fait,
il défend son peuple avec une sorte de
drapeau comme ça, mais il est
antagoniste à son peuple. D'ailleurs,
son peuple se se fout complètement de
Poutine, hein. Quand on a vu avec
Prigogine, hein, quand Prigogine a voulu
un peu prendre le pouvoir là, sorte de
coup d'état d'opérette là, euh les quand
on a ils intervie enfin les journalistes
intervie les les citoyens quoi. En fait,
ben c'est pour eux, bah pourquoi pas
Brigogine quoi ? Voilà.
Ça remonte à quand la dernière fois que
vous avez été en Russie ? Je suis jamais
allé à Russie donc je c'est vrai que je
connais pas le terrain. Donc c'est pour
ça je là je mais mais disons enfin de ce
que j'entends de façon très théorique
euh c'est que il y a il y a une capacité
voilà bah encaisser les chocs qui est
quand même supérieure à certainement
d'autres pays quoi.
Un premier exemple quand ça s'est cassé
la figure comme c'était le système
soviétique leur barre d'immeuble ils
avaient tous des transports en commun
des stations de métro en de chez eux. La
grand-mère elle faisait pousser encore
des patates en bru de Moscou. Ils
avaient l'habitude de vivre rudement. H
si ça nous arrive par exemple aux
États-Unis en Europe
Ouais. que le le l'état maman état ou
papa état
Calanche Titube
Ouais ouais alors je truche
ouais'est-se Alors c'est bah en fait
faut faut aller voir sur le tissu social
euh en France en Europe c'est le tissu
des association c'est le premier
kilomètre de la démocratie et donc c'est
bah il est très dense hein en enfin en
France en particulier hein la Belgique
même ils sont jaloux de nous he alors
que pourtant ils ont un super tissu
quand mme mais bon en France il y a un
tissu associatif énorme. Alors, aux
États-Unis, ça sera pas le tissu
associatif, ce sera le tissu cultuel,
donc ce sera les églises.
Donc là, un autre une autre philosophie
quoi, ça sera plus problématique. C'est
très clairement ça qui qui fait le tissu
social local quoi. Donc c'est par des
églises. Donc là, ça risque d'être
beaucoup plus sectaire.
Pourquoi vous parlez pas du tissu des
mafieux ?
Ah oui, ben il existe aussi. Mais bah
oui, ben il sera là aussi hein, bien
sûr. Mais alors c'est c'est là où
peut-être on a une petite divergence,
c'est que euh pour moi un système
robuste euh il est robuste si il
autorise 5 à 10 % de mafieux quoi. En
fait, il encaisse le choc, quoi. Il y a
de la fraude, il y a un peu de fraude,
mais c'est pas très grave parce que vu
que c'est robuste, on peut avoir un peu
de marge de mainœuvre quoi. Mais par
contre, c'est quand ça devient dominant
mafieux, enfin là, ça devient une
mafieocratie. Là, c'est différent
évidemment quoi.
Cleptoocratie sinon.
CL Voilà, exactement. Oui. Ben voilà.
Mais alors le faut aussi euh alors c'est
là parce que je suis trop optimiste,
mais un milieu un monde fluctuant, c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour une
dictature de rester en place longtemps
parce que les gens sont pas contents,
hein. Ils se font inonder une fois, deux
fois, trois fois. Euh l'inondation a
rien à voir avec le système dictatorial,
mais c'est juste qu'ils sont pas
contents, quoi. Donc ils sont ils vont
se rebeller beaucoup plus vite. La
dictature, c'est plus facile quand on
arrose tout le monde avec de l'argent ou
du pétrole, quoi.
Qu'on leur tape dessus.
Oui, on leur tape dessus. Mais en fait
c'est comment dire c'est enfin là aussi
je suis pas du tout expert de ces
domaines là mais c'est mon impression
c'est c'est que quand ça fluctue
vraiment beaucoup en fait on y arrive
plus quoi. On a vu d'ailleurs en Chine
le mouvement des pages blanches ça
commençait quand même à craquer quoi.
Expliquer les pages blanches pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas.
Ouais bah c'est quand bah ça près 3 ans
de confinement les gens ont finit par
péter un câble he quand même en se
disant bah là c'est plus possible quoi.
On voit bien que tout le monde est sorti
partout ailleurs dans le monde. Pourquoi
nous on reste ? Et donc vu qu'ils
pouvaient pas parler, ils ont ils sont
sortis avec une page à qu blanche.
Quelle a été votre lecture du fait que
les Chinois prolongent leurs mesures
sanitaires plus que les autres ?
Ouais bah c'est le contrôle c'est c'est
performance et contrôle sont vont main
dans la main efficacité efficience
contrôle de sa sécurité
réducteur quand même.
Oui bien sûr. Bah là je vais la serp je
vais la serpent. Les Chinois savent
pertinemment ce que peut faire un
coronavirus sur une population. Ouais.
En terme de c'estquel débilitante à long
terme
ils anticipent un impact social,
économique, sanitaire à long terme. Ils
se disent "Bon, si on confine 3 semaines
de plus, on gagne trois points de PIB
dans les 15 prochaines années."
Ouais. Je je suis pas pour moi c'est je
enfin alors j'en sais rien mais donc là
là je je sors de mon domaine de
compétence. Donc c'est une opinion,
c'est pas du fait scientifique hein, je
préfère le dire. Moi, j'ai plutôt eu
l'impression que c'était enfin que c'est
un système politique qui est forcément
dans le contrôle. C'est une dictature,
enfin, il y a un seul parti et cetera et
ce qui tient le pays, c'est encore une
fois une s une forme de culture hein et
puis aussi une sorte de rançon
économique d'un système qui qui
fonctionne finalement. Enfin, au jour le
jour, les gens sont nourris et cetera
quoi.
Peut-être une rancune d'avoir été détrôé
par les anglais qui ont transformé bien
sûr. Voilà, et cetera mais mais donc il
a Ouais, bien sûr, il y a il y a
certainement c'est toujours
multifactorial he ces trucs là. Mais euh
mais cette idée du contrôle euh c'est en
fait c'est une fois qu'on est dans le
contrôle, on peut plus s'en sortir. Bah
le canal de SU, c'est exactement ça.
C'est à partir du moment où on contrôle,
on s'est vraiment canalisé et donc on
peut plus enlever des couches, on peut
plus soustraire quoi, on ne peut que
ajouter du contrôle. Donc c'est une
c'est presque un effet rebond sur le
contrôle. Et d'ailleurs, c'est ce qu'on
voit avec l'informatique, hein. Euh, il
y a mot de passe, maintenant, il y a
double authentification et puis et
cetera, quoi. Donc c'est en fait, on on
narrête pas de rajouter des couches de
contrôle jusqu'à ce que ça devienne
impossible de communiquer les uns avec
les autres par l'informatique, quoi.
Comment vous voyez le basculement des
consciences ? Est-ce qu'il va falloir un
élément exotique extérieur
qui fasse prendre conscience à
l'ensemble de l'humanité au même moment
avec une synchronicité qu'il faut
implémenter des des des couches de de
robustesse ? Où est-ce que vous voyez
par exemple la France dire bon on est
français, on va ralentir, on va
implémenter de la robustesse
et on va se faire dépesser sur sur le
l'échiquier de la guerre économique.
Bon, c'est pas vraiment un choix ça en
fait.
Comment
c'est pas vraiment un choix entre les
deux options.
Ah oui, non, c'est pas un choix. Non, on
va subir.
Alors, ben oui, moi je je suis assez
d'accord. Je pense qu'il y aura en fait,
il y a des crises hein, on est dans le
monde de la polycrise, donc il y a des
crises successives. Il y a une crise un
jour qui va en effet certainement aider
au basculement. Ce sera peut-être pas la
crise de trop.
Alors bah c'est possible, c'est très
difficile pour moi en fait c'est c'est
ça sera jamais une crise quoi. Enfin
c'est toujours une série de crises en
fait là les enchaînent he les crises he
Covid, Ukraine et compagnie quoi. Donc
voilà il y en a il y en a plein mais
mais voilà pour moi donc c'est en effet
il faut que on ne on ne bascule pas
quand il y a pas de crise, il faut une
crise pour en fait avoir ce moment
d'arrêt où d'un seul coup on est en
dissonance avec le monde quoi. Et donc
sa trajectoire n'est plus alignée avec
la planète et un moment on déraille
quoi. C'est c'est le hamster qui est
dans sa roue, hein. En fait, ça c'est la
différence qu' entre une crise et être
dans le pétra. En fait, un hamster qui
est dans sa roue, ben il est dans le
péra, en fait. il tourne, il tourne, il
accélère et plus il accélère, il doit
accélérer quoi. Donc c'est ça c'est être
dans le pétrin et puis il y a un jour il
déraille, ça c'est la crise et c'est
très flippant hein parce que d'un seul
coup on sort de sa zone de confort
quelque part mais c'est aussi très
fertile. C'est la fameuse opportunité de
la crise, c'est qu'en fait quand on
déraille et ben enfin on est sorti du
péin quoi. Il y a c'est toujours associé
à ça. Donc la crise ça peut être très ça
peut faire peur, ça peut être
dramatique, ça peut faire du dégât mais
c'est toujours la sortie du pétrin. Donc
on est sorti du pétin et alors bah on
peut imaginer que le le basculement qui
arrive ce soir en est fait ça quoi que
il y a un événement externe, il y en a
déjà eu quelquesuns quand même en France
les gilets jaunes et cetera, Covid
compagnie que ça nous aide à dérailler
quoi finalement
si je vous comprends bien nos
gouvernants pour prolonger les courbes
font de la cavalerie de la fuite en
avant
court après la carotte de la croissance
exponentielle
infinie. Ouais,
ça ça calanche, ils se font emmener.
Ouais.
Et quand on commence à récupérer un peu
notre sens de l'orientation, on recrée.
Moi, je vous je vous je vous je vous
mets ça d'une avec une autre analogie.
On est dans un avion. Hm
hm.
On perd notre vitesse et on décroche. Hm
Et puis on a plus d'essence pour
remettre les réacteurs.
Alors, allez expliquer à une population
que bon bah, on va s'écraser mais ce
sera positif parce qu'il y en a qui vont
survivre. H
comme on est en pleine montagne, ils
pourront manger les cadavres de des
autres passagers et puis recréer un
nouveau monde. Nous, on sera tous
gentils et puis on se donnera la main,
on sera collaboratif
et on aura tous un pince. J'aime la
planète Terre.
Ouais,
ça risque de piquer un peu. C'estàd que
si je conçois votre façon de penser, je
me dis
et c'est oui oui au pays des merveilles.
Non non. Alors oui, alors je comprends.
Alors l'analgie de l'avion est très bien
en fait. Alors nous ce qu'on est en
train de faire actuellement là, donc on
est dans un avion,
on a tous les signaux qui disent qu'on
ne va pas on va pas arriver à l'aéroport
hein, on va tomber avant l'aéroport et
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On dit à
tout le monde qu'on les upgrade en
business class
et robe à volonté.
Voilà, c'est ça exactement. Donc en fait
c'est vraiment ça qu'on fait c'est on
est vraiment dans ce monde là. Et donc
du coup alors c'est joyeux quoi, par
dire enfin joyeux euh un peu euh cynique
hein, mais c'est c'est euh dans d'un sur
tout le coup là euh ah bah super, on est
upgradé quoi. Mais sauf que l'avion euh
il n'arrive toujours pas à l'aéroport.
Donc en fait, on s'occupe pas de la
carlingue quoi. On s'occupe vraiment que
de l'intérieur du confort interne. Donc
en fait, c'est un peu voilà
l'écosystème, ça serait voilà le
cockpit, enfin c'est tout ça quoi. Et du
coup bah moi ce que je dirais plutôt, ce
serait pas forcément le qu'on décroche
et qu'on tombe. C'est qu'on va amérir.
On va pas atterrir, on va amérir. On va
tomber donc avec un avion qui n'est pas
adapté à aller sur l'eau. Alors qui peut
un peu aller sur l'eau, il va y avoir
des vagues et il va falloir atterrir sur
la mer. Il y aura pas de secours.
Et il y aura pas de secours. Donc il va
falloir que nous euh localement Alors là
je suis un peu collapsologue hein. Enfin
très clairement.
Vous avez déjà fait un stage commando ?
Non, j'ai pas fait une stage au
commando. Non, mais c'est vrai que ça
serait simplement mais mais ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est que c'est
amérière, ça peut faire peur et je
comprends parce que c'est vraiment un
autre monde. Mais par contre euh l'avion
qui va d'un aéroport à l'autre euh c'est
c'était encore plus débile quoi. Je veux
dire, c'est de dans le le enfin c'est
c'est accélérer le temps. Enfin, c'est
c'est le c'est l'époque où on utilisait
de la matière pour gagner du temps quoi.
Alors que maintenant on va plutôt du du
temps pour préserver la matière quoi. On
va plutôt voilà remplacer des tas de
d'objets qu'on utilisait avant de façon
délirante. Faire pousser des plantes
pour produire des biomasses, pour
remplacer le pétrole, les métaux et tout
ça. Donc c'est on va plutôt dans ce
monde là. Améririr, ça veut dire ça
aussi hein. Ça veut dire non pas
décarboner l'économie mais recarboner
l'économie. c'est en fait on va tout
remplacer quoi, on va tout changer. Euh
et donc c'est euh c'est c'est la partie
euh euh qui est plus joyeuse dans
l'histoire, c'est que la ce que je dis
d'ailleurs aux jeunes que je croise,
c'est que ce sera la première génération
qui aura la légitimité et le pouvoir de
tout changer parce que le monde qui
vient sera très différent.
Question internet, j'en prends une parce
que ça me ça me fait raisonner avec vos
propos. Bonsoir et merci pour votre
temps. D'un point de vue pragmatique et
factuel, que conseillez-vous aux jeunes
ayant la conscience de notre chute ? À
vos yeux, que pouvons-on espérer
réellement ? Postcryptome, j'ai 24 ans.
Ouais, bah c'est exactement ça. Donc
pour moi en fait c'est bah quand je dis
que on rentre dans l'histoire, c'est y
compris pour tout le monde. C'est pas
que le personnel politique. Donc en fait
aujourd'hui là, on rentre dans un monde
fluctuant. Si on a compris que dans un
monde fluctuant, il faut faire de la
robustesse et si on sait que pour faire
la robustesse, faut baisser en
performance. Donc faut mettre du jeu
dans les rouages, faut se construire sur
l'hétérogénité, l'aléatoire, les
incohérences, l'inachèvement. Donc des
valeurs. Donc ça c'est le vivant qui
nous dit ça. Enfin là c'est le
biologiste qui parle. Les êtres vivants
sont robustes parce qu'ils ne sont pas
performants. Et donc c'est une c'est une
grille de lecture pour habiter le monde
qui vient. Donc en fait ça nous
reconnecte au vivant et en plus ça
développe de la robustesse dans un monde
fluctuant. Ça nécessiterait une
psychothérapie à échelle mondiale sur 30
ans.
Non, je crois pas parce qu'en fait c'est
déjà là au marge en fait c'est la
robustesse. C'est un peu l'ombrelle qui
rassemble des tas de projets qui sont
déjà dans la robustesse en fait qui sont
déjà adaptés au monde de flcture. C'est
les coopératifs, c'est les scopes, c'est
les l'agroécologie, les jardins créoles
dans les Caraïbes, enfin c'est tout ça
quoi.
Et moi je vous dis euh adhérence,
catatonie intellectuelle et
émotionnelle, passivité tétanie. Ouais,
mais ça pour moi c'est ça c'est plutôt
la c'est entre depuis 2000 quoi. C'est
qu'en fait on est passé pas tous hein,
chacun va passer par ces étapesl par la
collapsologie, par le voilà le la peur
de l'effondrement.
C'est des moments de grande solitude
hein quand même. Enfin c'est voilà sur
la nostalgie et cetera quoi. Donc c'est
des moments où on se dit bah on va en
fait c'est foutu quoi. On va pas y
arriver.
Dire quoi après chaque phrase s'il vous
plaît.
Ah oui d'accord. J'ai peut-être un tic
de langage mais en fait voilà, il y a
des moments où on est voilà en fait un
peu comme ça sidéré mais il y a après
quelque chose qui se passe quoi. En fait
quand c'est c'est comme si on se
rapprochait en gros il y a le sujet
socio-écologique est très loin. Il y a
un moment on y pense pas quoi. Voilà
c'est un peu au même niveau que le le
pouvoir d'achat et puis on se rapproche
de la falaise, on s'intéresse, on se dit
tiens le question socioécologique c'est
quand même important. Donc on se
rapproche de la falaise et puis on est
au pied de la falaise et d'un seul coup
on se dit "Ah oui, là en fait c'est trop
haut, on va pas y arriver quoi." Et donc
ça c'est le moment voilà de de crise
d'effondrement quoi. Et puis après il
faut juste regarder euh sur les côtés,
il y a des chemins de traverse quoi. Euh
très clairement et bah la robustesse,
c'est ça qui est en fait avec la
robustesse, on aura pas le choix d'avoir
le choix. C'est qu'en fait quand on fait
de la robustesse, en fait on multiplie
les interactions avec son territoire.
C'est plus une question de temps, on n
pas le temps. C'est c'est plus ça le
sujet, c'est qu'est-ce que je fais dans
mon territoire ? comment mes activités
raisonnent avec mon territoire. Quand
j'y raisonne, c'est vraiment à la rosa
quoi que ça ça qu'il y a vraiment des
interactions directes, des vibrations
avec le territoire quoi.
Comment vous percevez l'intelligence
artificielle,
tout ce mouvement technolutionniste de
transfert de conscience dans un
ordinateur ou de vie éternelle ou
d'optimisation, d'upgrade ? Est-ce que
c'est peut-être aussi une un chemin de
traverse ?
Alors non, je crois pas. Pour moi, Lia,
c'est c'est très clair. Lia dans un
monde qui est drogué à la performance,
c'est au service de la performance tout
simplement.
De la poésie.
Alors ouais bah oui, alors il y en a un
peu mais c'est vrai. Alors c'est pour
moi tout ce qui sort alia négative bah
c'est par exemple total qui va utiliser
de l'IA pour trouver des nouveaux champs
pétrolifères. Donc là c'est génial,
c'est de l'IA pour aller encore plus
dans la performance, dans
l'extractivisme et cetera. Mais il y a
aussi à un effet plus poétique, c'est
celle qui est plutôt au service de la
sérendipité euh où en fait on va on va
se se s'exposer à des choses qu'on a pas
attendu quoi. Donc ça c'est plutôt de la
robustesse. Donc c'est pas pour
condamner l'IA en telle hein. C'est
c'est son contexte qui fait que l'IA
devient intoxique quoi. Une a dans une
dans un bain de performance c'est de
l'IA au service de la performance et
donc au service de la violence quoi.
Est-ce que vous voyez Lia comme
une super conscience une super
administration ? pouvons administrer
une façon plus je dirais productive.
Ouais.
Alors non, en fait sur Li je suis Gérard
Berry hein, médaille d'or du CNRS 2014
qui dans un article du Nouvel se disait
l'ordinateur est complètement con.
Je cite hein et c'est un informaticien
qui dit ça et en fait il a Bayard dit la
même chose.
Ouais bien sûr mais en fait c'est le
donc l'a le numérique un ordinateur
c'est du calcul donc en fait c'est comme
nous si on réduisait un humain à un
cerveau. Bah sauf qu'en fait notre
relation au monde ne passe pas par le
cerveau, ça passe par le corps et les I
n'ont pas de corps. Donc les relations
enfin les les I n'ont pas de relation au
monde
pour l'instant. Alors, c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait imaginer des cborgs avec mais
regarder un un match de foot avec des
robots, vous allez voir, on en est loin
quand même. Bon, on y est pas encore
quoi. Mais ça peut arriver hein. C'est
vrai, un jour peut-être qu'on aura des
cibors qui sont vraiment coincor quoi
vraiment. Mais en tout cas, pour
l'instant, l'IA actuelle n'a pas de
corps. On peut assez facilement la faire
euh dévier et dire des choses
complètement aberrantes. Si on dit à une
IA qui qu'il faut manger des cailloux
quand on a une gastroentérite, si elle
le dit si on lui dit assez souvent, elle
va dire ça à toute la planète, hein.
Donc euh c'est elle a pas de relation
quoi au monde.
Revenons sur les préconisations et la
question de l'architecte. Euh d'un point
de vue pragmatique et factuel, que
conseillez-vous aux jeunes ayant la
conscience de notre chute ?
Ouais. Ben alors moi alors moi ce que je
j'aurais tens à dire c'est vous allez me
voir venir à 3 km faire un audit de
robustesse. Donc ça veut dire que dans
son organisation, dans son association,
dans son entreprise, enfin dans son
milieu quoi, un audit de robustesse,
c'est faire la liste des
contreperformances
et au lieu de vouloir les évacuer de
voir en quoi ça ajoute du jeu dans les
rouages et donc de la robustesse.
l'exemple typique hein pour une
entreprise ou un
alors alors je pensais pas au qu d'ors
oui dans les contre alors après il faut
faire attention parce qu'il y a aussi
des contreperformances qui vont vraiment
nulle part mais un exemple plus simple
he plus anecdotique c'est la pose café
quoi. Une pose café c'est pas un moment
de performance mais c'est un moment où
on fait du lien social du du sentiment
d'appartenance on fait même de la
serendipité aussi hein des collisions
d'idées et cetera donc on fait de
l'innovation bah ça c'est de la
robustesse. Donc en fait un moment de
contreperformance est hyper nécessaire
pour ajouter du jeu dans la rouage et
pour nourrir la robustesse. Et donc moi
ce que j'aurais enfin il y a plein de
choses qu'on peut suggérer à quelqu'un
qui a 24 ans dans ce monde là en fait
c'est c'est de dire en fait travaillez
votre robustesse, pratiquez votre
robustesse.
L'interrogatoire commence, je sais pas
si vous avez
Oui, la lumière change. Oui, voilà,
c'est c'est le basculement c'est ça
fluctue aussi. C'est ça. Mais c'est bien
mais c'est ça en fait. Voilà, j'ai
pratiquer la russesse. Donc ça veut dire
bah aller voir dans des associations,
pratiquer le dialogue contradictoire, le
désaccord fécond de Patrick Vivret quoi.
Voilà, c'est en fait devenait des
coopérateurs.
C'est pas ça qui se passe en ce moment,
le dialogue contradictoire, l'échange.
Ouais.
Maintenant, vous avez vu comme nous
chacun est dans sa paroisse, ils
deviennent de plus en plus sectaires,
ils deviennent de plus en plus
agressifs. On n' pas le droit de
d'adresser la parole à autre chose que
sa paroisse.
Mais ça c'est le délire performant.
C'est comme Elon Musk qui veut aller sur
Mars, c'est qu'en fait ceux qui sont
comme ça là, les ultra performants
finalement bah ils sont aussi ils sont
en train de révéler à quel point ils ont
été formés à la compétition. Et donc en
fait c'est complètement inutile.
Aujourd'hui, on a là 577 députés qui ont
été formés à la compétition et on leur
demande de faire des coalitions. En
fait, ils sont incompétents à faire des
coalitions. Donc en fait, c'est parce
qu'on les a pas formé à être
coopérateur. La coopération c'est très
compliqué pour se former à la
coopération. La compétition c'est très
simple hein, c'est les plus violents qui
gagnent. Donc là comme ça voilà je fais
gagner à tout le monde 5 ans d'école de
commerce hein. C'est les plus violents
qui gagnent. Donc en fait la coopération
par contre c'est très compliqué. Il faut
apprendre à parler avec des gens qui ont
différentes traditions, différentes
cultures. Faut s'exposer à des conflits,
faut savoir résoudre les conflits. Enfin
c'est très compliqué. Donc l'école de la
coopération c'est ça. Enfin avant de
mettre des panneaux solaires sur les
toits, faut d'abord faire de la
coopération. On aura besoin de
coopérateurs dans un monde fluctuant.
Deux diplomates peut-être.
Oui, des diplomates. Voilà. mais des
diplomates qui intègrent les non
humains. C'est c'est vraiment le contrat
naturel de Michel Ser et cetera. Donc
c'est c'est des c'est de la diplomatie
entre humains et avec les non humains où
on en fait on on sort d'une d'un
dualisme nature culture quoi. On est
vraiment les trois. En gros, c'est ce
que je dis souvent he c'est quand je
vois des entrepreneurs, je leur dis que
la loi de l'offre à la demande n'a aucun
sens parce que la loi de l'offre et à la
demande, c'est des humains qui
s'échangent des biens et des services et
qui considèrent que la nature est
gratuite et illimitée. Donc bah c'est
évidemment pas vrai à l'échelle d'une
vie humaine, c'est pas vrai. Donc la
vraie loi, c'est la loi des besoins et
des ressources. Loi des besoins et des
ressources. Et en fait dans la loi des
besoins et des ressources, on ajoute le
troisème fil de la prise de terre avec
un grand thé. Et là, en fait, la nature
devient un partenaire. Et là, ça change
tout. On n'est plus du tout
extractiviste forcément quoi parce qu'en
fait on est vraiment en interaction à
égalité entre des humains et des non
humains quoi. Et donc cette diplomatie
là euh terrienne terrestre euh ce serait
ça. Ça c'est du Bruno Latour dans le
texte hein.
Si on n'y arrive pas, qu'est-ce qui va
se passer ?
Ah bah là c'est du suicide hein très
clairement. Si si on n'est pas capable
de se reconnecter au vivant. Et donc
quand je dis reconnecter au vivant,
c'est pas juste faire attention aux
orchidés sauvages, c'est vraiment penser
le monde fluctuant comme les êtres
vivants le pensent. c'estàd en
augmentant leur robustesse, hein. Si on
le fait pas euh ça veut dire qu'en fait
on va continuer sur le chemin
performant. Et donc c'est la stratégie
du parasite. Donc c'est en fait c'est la
stratégie euh bah des des parasites, il
y en a plein hein sur Terre. Euh et donc
un exemple de gros parasites, c'est les
blue malgares. Les les blue malgar donc
c'est des ciobactéries qui pululent dans
les dans les océans, dans les lacs.
Voilà. et qui quand il fait chaud, quand
il y a beaucoup de nitrate, beaucoup de
phosphate donc il prolifère, enfin elle
prolifère, ce sont des algues euh et
elle finit par tout tuer sur sur le
passage quoi. Donc ça c'est c'est un
parasite ça. Bah oui, voilà, c'est on
c'est très analogue à ce qu'on fait
hein, nous hein, les humains. Et sauf
que en fait quand il y a plus de
ressources parce qu'elles ont tout
mangé, elle collapse et ça va très vite
hein. C'est vraiment un collapse comme
ça. Donc en fait alors les mêmes algues
si on les met dans un milieu dans de
l'eau froide avec moins de nitrate,
moins de phosphate, elles vont interagir
avec les autres êtres vivants et là ça
va être plutôt des stratégies de
coopération et donc ça sera plus
fluctuant voilà mais ça va vraiment
vivre quoi. Et dans la
ça se passe le sevrage de l'algue.
Bah c'est oui c'est compliqué. C'est
compliqué. Alors en plus les algues
elles peuvent faire des sports et cetera
donc c'est encore une autre chose hein.
Mais mais c'est oui le le bah le sevage
est compliqué clairement. C'est en fait
la partie difficile pour moi, c'est en
fait quand on est dans un milieu qui est
abondant en ressources et stable, on
peut faire de la performance. Ça marche
très bien en fait. Il y a beaucoup de
retours sur investissement quoi. On peut
le dire comme ça. Quand on est en état
de pénurie ou en tout cas de moins forte
abondance et qu'on fait de la
coopération, ça se passe très bien
aussi. La période difficile, c'est entre
les deux parce que entre les deux
culturellement ou en tout cas les les
systèmes sont encore dans le monde de la
performance alors qu'on est en pénurie.
Et alors là en fait on accélère la
pénurie parce queil y a un décalage
quoi. On on est plus adapté à son
environnement. On est exactement
là-dedans maintenant là. Enfin on voit
bien les pénuries de phosphate. Enfin il
y en a plein partout hein. Enfin c'est
de moutarde aussi anecdotiquement.
Voilà, c'est ces ces pénuries là en fait
elles révèlent qu'on arrive ben de
nouveau he des nouveaux signes, qu'on
arrive au bout d'un système et donc il
va falloir développer notre robustesse.
Mais par rapport aux algues qui n'ont
pas de capacité de spéculation, elles
vont pas pouvoir
c'est qu'elles ont le même la même
capacité de spéculation qu'un politique.
Bah quand je je serais moins méchant
quand même. Il y en a certains qui
arrivent à se projeter.
Il y en a qui arrivent quand même à se
projeter. Mais mais nous les humains
Gutter Randers disait qu'on pouvait pas
se représenter l'avenir. Bah en fait oui
mais sauf que non en fait on peut on se
représente la modisation informatique le
rapport MDOS c'était de la
représentation du futur. Donc on a tout
hein. Donc on a pas d'excuses quoi pour
ne pas le faire parce qu'on sait ce qui
va se passer quoi
et responsable mais pas coupable. C'est
ça.
Vous avez compris ma blague sur le
système politique.
Quelle émergence et quel type de forme
politique ça va prendre ? Parce que il
faut aussi qu'il y ait de
l'administration dans tout ça. Il faut
aussi qu'il y ait une moelle épinière.
Ouais. Ben là aussi c'est beaucoup plus
joyeux. En fait dans le monde de la
performance, on fait de la performance
administrative. Donc on empile des
règles sur des règles sur des règles sur
des règles. À la fin on a un règlement
avec 1500 règles que personne connaît,
personne comprend et du coup c'est la
performance administrative
contreproductive. Donc dans le monde de
la robustesse, on a plutôt une dizaine
de lois euh lâches euh avec beaucoup de
marges de manœuvre. On peut les
interpréter différemment et c'est très
situé. Donc ça veut dire que dans un
territoire, on va s'aligner avec les 10
principes quoi. Euh enfin ou les 12
principes enf voilà, je sais pas que qui
sont un peu lâches mais par contre euh
c'est un peu bricolé au niveau local
quoi. Il y a aussi donc les conventions
citoyennes dont j'ai parlé. En fait, moi
un bon modèle c'est Eline Orstrom sur
les communs. C'est qu'en fait
certainement que dans le monde
fluctuant, enfin dans le monde
performant, c'est beaucoup public privé
hein, c'est un peu une binarité. Et ben
dans le monde robuste de robuste, les
communs vont prendre beaucoup plus de
poids. Mais en fait, c'est ce qu'on voit
hein, d'ailleurs, il y a de plus en plus
de communs, y compris dans le monde
informatique. D'ailleurs, hein,
je vous ouvre une parenthèse, question
internet.
Ouais.
Que je découvre avec vous en même temps.
Quand je vous écoute, je me sens en
décalage complet avec vos propos.
OK. Après avoir lu Ah, j'ai du mal à
chaque fois à prononcer euh cet
économiste. Après avoir lu Ein Rand, je
ne crois plus en l'État comme moyen de
parvenir au bonheur commun. J'ai 28 ans,
je travaille dans la finance et investi
une part très importante de mon salaire
au aux États-Unis.
Je ne je ne crois plus en l'État et je
pense qu'une partie importante de la
jeunesse aussi. Bon, c'était pas
vraiment une question, c'était un
commentaire. Ouais, mais je peux
répondre ou en tout cas commenter le
commentaire le alors dans un faut bien
comprendre que les états faillis enfin
quand il y a un état failli ça se passe
très mal. Ça faut quand même le réaliser
dans le monde.
Avant on maquille un peu les comptes.
Oui mais quand même. Enfin faut le
savoir. C'est que quand il y a un état
failli, ça se passe très mal. Donc on a
besoin d'un état. C'est juste que la
fonction de l'État change. Dans le monde
performant, stable abondant ressources.
Le rôle de l'État c'est d'être dans le
pouvoir, d'être un meneur qui dit "Je
veux et je sais comment faire."
Et donc ça évidemment que c'est assez
stérile dans un monde structurant parce
que dans le monde abondant ressources
c'est pas très grave quoi. Si l'état se
plou
je veux et qu'est-ce que vous avez dit
après ?
Et je sais comment faire.
Et soyez fier des amateurs.
Oui. Bah voilà, ça c'est exactement en
fait c'est très excluant hein. C'est
exactement c'est une posture descendante
excluante quoi. Bah dans le monde
fluctuant l'État le décideur c'est
quelqu'un qui dit "J'ai envie et je ne
sais pas comment faire." En fait c'est
quelqu'un qui dit "J'ai besoin d'aide."
Et donc l'État, c'est plutôt quelqu'un
qui va mettre en résonance des
initiatives des citoyens, mais il faut
qu'elle se mette en résonance et ça ça
va en fait créer un projet. Et ce qu'on
a mis au milieu de la table, c'est le
manque de solution. Ça ça fédère, ça
mobilise un collectif et ça c'est
robuste parce que même si le décideur
n'est plus là, même si l'État a des
flottements, le collectif s'est
construit et il va se propager, se
déployer. Et donc ça c'est de la
robustesse sur le temps long. Et en
fait, le rôle de l'État, il est vraiment
crucial, c'est celui-là, c'est de mettre
en résonance toutes les initiatives
locales. Parce que sinon l'autre
solution, c'est le survivalisme. Donc
là, en fait, le survivalisme radical,
hein. Donc c'est là, on fait que des
petites autonomies locales dans son
territoire en pensant qu'avec ça, on va
survie. Bah, évidemment que ça marche
pas. Donc là, je renvoie à Orstrom euh
un des huit principes pour que les
communs restent communs pendant des
siècles, hein. Donc c'est un vrai test
de robustesse, c'est la mise en réseau,
hein. Euh, il faut qu'il y ait une
reconnaissance par une entité externe de
l'initiative locale. S'il y a pas de
reconnaissance, il y a pas de lien, ça
perd. En fait, c'est la tragédie des
communs.
Vous avez un ami imaginaire ?
Ouais.
Oui.
Oui. Enfin, peut-être. Ouais, je sais.
C'est une question.
Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Alors, j'ai j'ai été croyant quand
j'étais petit. Là, je suis plus croyant.
Puis la science a tué Dieu, c'est ça.
C'est même Ouais, je sais pas. C'est une
évolution mais certainement
multifactoriel aussi mais je ne suis pas
croyant. Non.
Vous avez de la famille avec François
Rufin ?
J'ai pas de famille. Oui, apparemment je
ressemble à François R j'ai pas j'ai pas
noté. Mais
question internet. En tant que citoyen
père, qu'est-ce que je dois faire pour
créer un parachute ? Ah oui, un
parachute. Ben le parachute, c'est le
tissu social, hein. La sécurité dans le
monde de la performance, c'est de
construire des barrières, de mettre des
caméra augmenté, de construire un bunker
extrêmement fragile. Euh ça n'a aucun
sens en fait parce que le jour où il y a
un méga feu euh d'avoir des barrières,
des caméras ou un booker, ça sert à
rien. Donc en fait, dans un monde
fluctuant, le parachute c'est le tissu
social. Il faut se connecter à son
territoire et aux gens de son
territoire. Donc ça peut être un club de
lecture, ça peut être un club de
céramique, j'en sais rien quoi. Ça peut
vraiment être des choses très très
différentes.
Club de tir, ouais, par exemple. Voilà,
pourquoi pas ? Oui, je comprends. Mais
mais c'est en fait avoir du lien social,
c'est ça la sécurité, hein. Et en fait,
c'est les dans un monde flant, ce sont
les plus robustes, hein, qui tiennent
quoi. Et ça, c'est la leçon de Darwin he
qu'on a très mal lu d'ailleurs.
Alors, c'est intéressant ça. Darwin,
vous parlez de robuste et d'individus
robustes.
Ouais.
Dans ce nouveau monde.
Ouais. où il y aura beaucoup moins de
ressources, beaucoup moins de tout ça.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens inadaptés
?
Ah bah alors c'est exactement alors
inadapté c'est c'est un c'est déjà un
problème de dire qu'ils sont inadaptés
parce que ça veut dire que on considère
que le monde dans lequel on est, il y a
qu'une voie. Donc dans un monde
fluctuant,
adapté au nouveau monde.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais justement, mais le
nouveau monde qui vient, il est pluriel.
Donc en fait personne est inadapté parce
qu'en fait ça change tout le temps. Donc
en fait c'est euh faut considérer que
dans le monde qui vient euh on va enfin
réaliser que tout le monde hein 100 % de
la population est vulnérable. C'est que
quand on parle des vulnérables he on
pense souvent aux personnes âgées, aux
handicapés donc en fait des gens qui
sont en dehors hein de la norme quoi.
Nous en fait on est tous vulnérables. À
un moment de notre vie on est tous
vulnérables. Il y un moment de la
journée on est vulnérable. Donc en fait
dans un monde fluctuant il y a pas de
d'histoire d'être inadapté en fait. Par
contre il y a des la question d'être
inadaptable.
les inadaptables. Alors ceux-là, ils
sont très canalisés, spécialisés dans un
couloir. Et ben ceux-là, ça va être très
compliqué pour eux parce que dans un
monde flutant, il va falloir être
capable de changer de métier, il va
falloir changer de philosophie, changer
de territoire et cetera. Donc en fait,
c'est Ouais, ça serait plutôt les
inadaptables qui m'inquiéteraient dans
le monde fluctuant.
C'est-à-dire que le carcarodon carcarias
de la finance
Ouais.
qui est toujours dans l'ultra
performance, dans la vitesse, dans le
matvu.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire de tout ça ?
Bah, peut-être qu'il fait de la cuisine,
peut-être qu'il écoute du jazz, donc il
aura d'autres compétences. Enfin, s'il
est adaptable et ben il va devenir il va
aller sur une radio faire des des toques
sur le jazz, quoi. Voilà. Mais il va
certainement plus faire du trading. Oui,
ça c'est sûr.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec la démographie
?
Alors bah la démographie, alors la bonne
nouvelle quand même c'est que au début
des années 2000 he c'est on pense encore
à les vieux discours sur la bombe
humaine hein sur on serait 12 14
milliards à la fin du siècle. Bon ben on
sait enfin c'est de plus en plus
consolidé que à partir de 2050 et voire
même avant ça va finir par ça va baisser
quoi. La Chine c'est depuis 2022 que ça
baisse. L'Inde c'est 2030 à peu près. Il
y a quelques pays africains sera 2040
mais c'est quelques pays africains. Donc
en fait voilà ça va basculer. Donc il y
a la démographie n est moins un problème
que ça été. En fait, le vieillissement
de la population, c'est la façon la plus
pacifique de faire un basculement
démographique finalement parce qu'il y a
d'autres façon de faire hein. Il y a les
familles, les épidémies hein, très
clairement. Mais là,
la question internet.
Ouais.
Bonsoir. Alors, je la pose quand même.
Bonsoir monsieur Olivier Amand. Question
: Y a-t-il des artisans du chaos ?
Quand, comment et pourquoi le devient-on
?
Bon, Hod Mosque, hein, c'est un artisan
du chaos hein au sens littéral. C'est
que les libertariens, je vais pas juste
mettre l' de masque, les libertariens,
c'est des gens qui pensent que la
liberté c'est une liberté sans limite.
Vous êtes communiste ?
Non, je suis pas communiste. Non, mais
il y a pas de lien avec la liberté. Le
la la liberté sûr qu' a le communiste,
c'est compliqué hein.
Oui, la liberté des libertariens, c'est
une liberté sans borne. Alors que la
liberté de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme, que ça soit déclaration
française ou des Nations- Unies, c'est
une définition négative. Elle s'arrête
là où commence celle d'autrui. Donc la
liberté des libertariens, ce n'est pas
de la liberté, c'est de l'augmentation
d'entropie. Quand on augmente
l'entropie, on fait du chaos. Et donc
quand on enlève les modérateurs sur
Twitter maintenant X, on fait du chaos
littéralement. Donc en fait c'est c'est
les libertariens sont plutôt au service
du KO. Quand on enlève les régulateurs
du Twitter, alors c'est un sujet qu'on
connaît un petit peu.
Ouais.
Entre laastrouturfing, vous connaissez
la struturfing ? c'est changer la
perception de l'opinion publique
en en en instylant
Oui, d'accord.
de faux mouvements pour pouvoir absorber
la masse et la diriger vers c'est du n
échelle.
OK, je comprends.
D'accord.
Quand la modération sur Twitter quand
tout le monde devient lanceur d'alerte
sur bah ça c'est des images de
terroristes qui coupent des têtes, ça
c'est des petits enfants, ils devraient
pas être là. Le monsieur avec la
moustache avec les petits enfants c'est
attention,
ça revient plus vite.
Ouais.
Ça modère plus vite, c'est plus
efficace.
Oui. Ben justement, c'est plus
performant donc c'est plus violent.
Violent dans quel sens ?
Ah bah c'est violent. C'estàd qu'en fait
al une équation toute simple quand on
fait de la performance heicacité
efficience atteindre son objectif avec
le moins de moyens possible c'est
toujours relatif. Donc quand on fait de
la performance en fait on fait de la
compétition. Dans une compétition qui
gagne ce sont toujours les plus
violents. Donc en fait c'est quand on
fait de la performance on fait de la
violence. Il y a il y a un truc tout
simple à faire c'est vous prenez
n'importe quel texte que vous voyez sur
internet ou ailleurs avec le mot
performance. Vous remplacez le mot
performance par violence et en fait ça a
une autre saveur quoi. En fait, ça
révèle la face cachée de la performance
quoi. Et donc bah alors on est
là-dedans.
Question internet. Qu'est-ce qui
empêcherait sa thèse de changement de
paradigme de se réaliser ?
Ah oui. Alors ben moi alors elle il y a
pas grand chose qui peut l'empêcher
parce que c'est dans un monde fluctuant.
En fait en fait vrai dire je ne vois pas
d'autres chemin. Je vais le dire aussi
simplement que ça.
Vous pensez un peu contre vous-même
notamant.
Ouais. Ah bah oui, bah en fait alors je
alors je vais revenir en arrière. Euh
quand euh
vous allez pas revenir en avant hein.
Non c'est vrai. C'est vrai. Mais quand
j'ai quand j'ai commencé à chercher sur
mes histoires de signaux mécaniques sur
les plantes là euh moi en fait j'avais
plaqué de la performance sur le vivant.
bibronné à du Darwin mal compris et
cetera quoi. En fait, je me disais "Ah
oui, bah justement bah l'histoire des
des plantes qui font des fleurs
homogènes là, je me disais bah en fait
c'est certainement il y a un programme
génétique qui vont faire que elles ont
toutes le la même forme de fleur quoi."
Et quand j'ai commencé et d'autres he il
y a pas que moi évidemment quand on a
commencé à regarder ça en fait on a vu
le contraire qu'en fait ce qui faisait
que c'était plus reproductif c'était que
c'était plus hétérogène au niveau local
quoi. Et donc je me suis rendu compte
que moi-même en fait j'étais à côté de
la plaque quoi. Donc là j'ai dû penser
contre moi-même en fait. J'ai pensé à
l'envers par rapport à et là je me suis
dit en fait oui c'est à l'endroit par
rapport au vivant quoi parce que c'est
c'est les données quoi. On peut pas
aller contre les données quoi. Les
données microscope elles nous disent ça
faut bien qu'on en fasse quelque chose
quoi. Et en fait quand on prend ça comme
ça et d'un seul coup on bascule quoi
pour le coup dans sa pensée quoi. On se
dit oui en fait c'est comme ça qu'on
fait de la robustesse en allant contre
la performance. Et après c'est là qu'on
lit des tas d'autres auteurs Darwin
Ulanovitz Jean-Pierre Robin enfin il y
en a plein les cyberneticiens ils en
parlent beaucoup en fait. C'est c'est
très connu ça cet équilibre performance
robustesse. C'est c'est complètement
établi. Il y a plus de question
là-dessus hein. Denis M en parle tout le
temps aussi. Donc c'est c'est vraiment
quelque chose de complètement établi.
Sauf que nous bah on s les biologistes
aussi on s'est fait bibronner à ça quoi.
Et donc du coup bah voilà parfois on
parle de blueprint en biologie de
programme de gène maître. Ça c'est c'est
de la c'est du créationnisme he quel
du récessitif photosomal.
Du récessif autosomal. Oui. Voilà. Bon
enfin voilà. Mais après, c'est de la
génétique. Bon, a y a des termes qui
sont utiles pour comprendre des choses
quoi. Mais le problème c'est comment on
fait pour se sortir de l'outil
didactique et pas en faire une pensée,
une philosophie du vivant qui devient
toxique quoi. C'est ça le problème. En
fait, on peut faire des petites
animations sur l'ordinateur pour montrer
comment une protéine interagit avec une
autre, quoi. Mais faut pas imaginer que
c'est vraiment ça qui se passe dans la
cellule, quoi. Parce que si on si c'est
ça qui se passe, alors c'est on est des
machines, quoi. C'est c'est en fait
c'est beaucoup plus variable, fluctuant
et cetera et on peut pas vraiment le
montrer facilement de façon didactique
avec une animation quoi. Enfin, c'est
trop compliqué quoi. Mais là, j'ai
dérivé he par rapport à la question.
Bah c'est toujours intéressant les
expériences de pensée dériver un petit
peu. Non,
bien sûr. Ah bah c'est c'est le but. Oui
oui c'est l'ambustesse aussi.
Par contre, j'ai pas répondu à la
question. Je sais plus ce qu' je vous
reposer la question.
Qu'est-ce qui empêcherait sa thèse de
changement de paradigme de ce
coup alors moi c'est ça je disais en
fait que moi je vois pas d'autres chemin
là c'est le côté bêtement
thermodynamicien j'ai envie de dire
c'est que dans un monde fluctuant ceux
qui survivent sont robustes donc en fait
les plus performant
pas l'air très robuste vous hein
ouais ben c'est possible peut-être que
je voilà mais mais c'est pas très grave
c'est le le le plus le plus performant
et le plus fragile. Donc en fait dans un
monde très fluctuant les plus
performants, c'est ceux qui sont le plus
canalisés. Donc en fait ça, ils vont
tomber quoi. Le
plus spécialisé, c'est ça.
Le plus spécialisé. Mais aussi celui qui
a une philosophie qui dit qu'il veut
absolument pas changer son logiciel.
Quoi que quand je dis logiciel là aussi,
je fais une une erreur hein. C'est pas
on a pas des logiciels dans dans le
cerveau quoi.
Sinon, on aurait encore des tigradons de
sabre.
Ah oui, bah par exemple. Oui, voilà.
Voilà. Mais alors mais justement alors
sur Darwin quand même parce que je c'est
c'est ce je l'ai évoqué là quand même
parce que ça peut surprendre quand on se
dit mais Darwin c'est un peu le monsieur
compétition survie des plus adaptés et
cetera. Alors vraiment lisez l'origine
des espèces. inextens quoi première
édition hein pas la pas les 5e et 6e là
où ça commence à Spencer a commencé à le
instrumentaliser pour une idéologie
voilà voilà après Galton après lui enfin
bon c'est vraiment on on est à fond dans
le génisme et tout ça donc en fait la
première édition euh dans le texte de
Darwin alors il y a la compétition he il
y a la sélection naturelle alors déjà
faut savoir que Darwin ne voulait pas
utiliser le mot sélection he il voulait
utiliser le mot préservation
différent quand même. Et puis aussi
quand on lit le texte en fait, on se
rend compte que Darwin il était très
intéressé par les organes rudimentaires.
Donc pour nous he les humains, c'est le
dernier orteil. Voilà, les les dents de
sagesse, l'appindice. Donc des choses
qui servent à rien. Enfin objectivement
ça ne sert à rien. Mais par contre pour
Darwin, c'est le laboratoire parce que
vu que ça sert à rien et ben ça va
pouvoir diverger. Et donc c'est de
l'adaptabilité, c'est pas de
l'adaptation. Donc en fait ce que nous
dit Darwin en creux, c'est que c'est la
survie des plus adaptables. Donc c'est
le contraire hein de la survie des plus
adaptés. Les plus adapté c'est les plus
spécialisés et en fait ils sont coincés
dans une niche écologique quoi. Et le
jour où le monde change, il meurt avec.
Donc il y a des impasses évolutifs.
D'ailleurs, ça arrive he le vivant se
trompe aussi hein. Évidemment, il est
pas parfait hein.
Est-ce qu'on n pas nous dans une impasse
évolutive ?
Alors exactement donc on est on est dans
une impasse évolutive en terme de
système socio-économique, c'est une
impasse évolutive très clairement. Et
donc là, on est en train de sortir du
néolithique. C'est pour ça que je dis
qu'on est dans un moment complètement
exceptionnel. On a enfin si je vais le
dire he que comme tout à l'heure, je
disais que on était dans le contrôle de
la nature dans le néoltique. Bah
aujourd'hui, on se rend compte que notre
excès de contrôle nous a fait perdre de
contrôle. Donc on est dans le moment de
la perte de contrôle. Il va falloir
vivre dans un monde où on a perdu le
contrôle. Ben ça c'est la c'est la
robustesse la réponse. Il y a il y a pas
de choix quoi. Et ceux qui restent sur
le thème du contrôle vont forcément se
planter quoi.
Vous avez déjà interagi avec quelqu'un
qui a toujours l'habitude de contrôler
tout de A à Z.
Et qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il perd
le contrôle ? Il s'agite, il crie, il
bouge les bras, il couleur dans tous les
sens. Ouais, c'est très difficile. Il
peut appuyer sur des boutons rouges
aussi hein. Donc c'est évidemment c'est
c'est ça qui est inquiétant en fait,
c'est que ceux qui qui ont le contrôle
et qui sont dans une stratégie de
contrôle, bah c'est du délire hein.
C'est docteur Famour. Enfin, c'est c'est
tout ça quoi. Donc c'est ça qui est qui
est flippant quelque part. Euh mais il y
a tous les autres euh ceux qui sont pas
dans le contrôle et en fait on est très
nombreux à être pas à ce point-là dans
le contrôle ont inventé des chemins de
traverse quand même.
Quand vous vous êtes rendu compte de
tout ça, vous aviez quel âge ?
Alors de tout ça c'estàd l'histoire de
robustesse et tout ça
de perte de contrôle qu'on allait dans
le mur qu'on était dans une impasse
évolutive et pour synthétiser
trivialement la chose
qu'on était entouré de connard.
D'accord. Alors bon là, j'ai moi j'ai 49
ans. Euh
ouais oui, on me le dit souvent mais
voilà. Moi j'ai 49 ans et bah c'est il y
a il y a allez il y a il y a 10 15 ans
quoi. Il y a 10 15 ans que j'ai vraiment
formalisé ça. C'est c'est venu
progressivement comme toujours hein.
Mais le déclic vraiment voilà c'est
c'était Ouais. il y a 10 15 ans quoi.
Dans ces eau là quoi.
Et ça c'est matérialisé comment votre
dépression ?
Alors moi ça s'est pas matérialisé par
une je me suis pas enfermé dans une
pièce ou quoi que ce soit. Non, ça a été
des moments de lecture en fait. Euh j'ai
voulu je me suis intéressé quoi. Euh
voilà. Alors, il y il y avait pas trop
de il y avait moins de podcast à
l'époque, quoi. Mais mais alors voilà,
on écoute, on lit et cetera, on essaie
de se renseigner quoi. On essaie de
trouver bah alors on cherche des
parachutes, on cherche d'autres voix
quoi. Et à un moment, on se dit "Ah oui,
en fait qu'on écoute Jean Covici, Pablo
Servi, on se dit "Ah ben non, en fait il
y a pas euh enfit, on voit bien la
critique du monde qu'on a passé quoi."
Donc c'est une impasse mais ça ouvre pas
trop de monde après quoi. Et donc c'est
ça moi qui m'a mobilisé en fait, c'est
justement le manque de solution. Et donc
euh en parallèle, j'étais chercheur euh
enfin je suis toujours chercheur dans
mon labo à travailler sur la robustesse
et il y a un moment ça a cliqué quoi. Je
me suis dit bah là en fait oui le vivant
il est il vit dans un monde futurant, il
fait de la robustesse. Et alors le
déclic hein quand même ce qui m'a aidé à
faire le déclic c'est notamment une
conférence à Berlin le campus
anthropocène
donc c'était en 2014 donc un peu après
quoi. 14. Donc c'est une donc c'était
pour 10 jours. Donc une conférence
longue hein parce que nous en général
c'est 3 4 jours une conférence
scientifique là c'était 10 jours euh
avec un/3 d'artistes un/ers de
scientifiquers de société civile.
Passionnant et c'était une en fait
c'était un campus où il y avait beaucoup
de moments lâches quoi, assez ouverts,
enfin vraiment très exploratoire et là
en fait il y a dans dans tout ce groupe
là il s'est passé quelque chose quoi. Il
y a il y a vraiment eu un déclic
collectif. C'est c'est les cocktails aux
champignons.
Alors peut-être il y avait il y avait
quelques cocktails. Ouais mais alors je
sais pas s'il y a des champignons
dedans. Mais en tout cas il y a il y a
eu un vrai là ils ont inventé quelque
chose hein quand même hein. C'est entre
le Max Pl et Max Plan qui est le la
maison des cultures du monde de Berlin
et ils ont trouvé une alchimie très
productive. Il y en a eu plusieurs après
ça a suivi quoi.
Pourquoi vous avez utilisé le mot
alchimie ?
Parce que c'est pas c'est pas de la
chimie quoi. C'est quelque chose je
c'est difficile à décrire. Je suis je
suis pas sûr que je serais même capable
de décrire ce qui s'est passé, mais
c'est
très c'est de la psychologie, c'est de
l'émotionnel,
c'est c'est des surprises, c'est des
moments d'ennui aussi. Donc c'est c'est
des choses un peu un peu
contreintuitives et qui et qui sè une
graine et qu'on veut arroser quoi.
Voilà. Et ça ça bah c'est un peu le
manque de solution qui donne envie de se
mobiliser quoi.
On veut s'aimer euh votre entourage que
ce soit professionnel ou personnel si on
peut aborder ce sujet-là.
Ouais.
Vous avez essayé des simer dans leur
tête. Comment ils vous ont perçu ?
Quelles ont été leurs adhérences ?
Comment ils ont verbalisé leurs
adhérences ou leur opposition ?
Ouais.
Comment ça s'est passé ? Alors ben en
fait sur le
Oui oui, c'est vrai, j' a pensé.
Il y a en fait il y a alors moi j'ai
beaucoup alors j'ai la chance d'avoir
beaucoup de retours positif. En même
temps, je pense que c'est plus facile de
faire un retour positif que de faire un
retour négatif. Donc c'est il y a un
biais voilà ça c'est normal, un billet
scientifique, j'ai envie de dire. Mais
ce que ce que j'entends souvent c'est
qu'en fait je rencontre beaucoup de gens
qui sont face à cet impasse de
l'effondrement quoi. Et qui se disent
"Mais comment on fait pour en sortir ?"
Et et cette idée de robustesse, ça a une
valeur, c'est que c'est pragmatique,
quoi. Voilà, dans un monde fluctuant, on
fait de la robustesse. Il y a il y a pas
tellement d'autre choses. Et quand on
comprend que pour faire la robustesse,
faut aller contre la performance, on se
rend compte que ce qu'on va vivre, c'est
pas une révolution technique, c'est une
révolution culturelle. C'est d'abord une
révolution culturelle. Et en fait d'un
seul coup, on se rend compte que tout ce
qu'on fait dans la vie de tous les jours
qui en général n'est pas très performant
en fait hein, on est un peu tous et
toutes des Gastons la gaffe, hein. Et
ben en fait c'est on se reconnecte à
notre vraie ontologie quoi, d'être
vivant qui n'est pas dans la performance
mais qui est dans la robustesse. Euh
quand on communique par exemple, bah là
moi j'arrête pas de d'éthiques de
langage, de me reprendre sur mes mots.
Donc en fait je n'ai pas une
communication performante. Mais par
contre le fait de pas parler
parfaitement comme ça,
ça vous donne un côté très touchant. B
voilà. Mais non, mais touchant où ça
donne confiance en fait, c'est qu'en
fait c'est mes erreurs qui installent un
climat de confiance. Si je ne faisais
pas d'erreur, si je parlais comme un
robot, ce serait très froid et surtout
ça ferait peur à tout le monde ou ça
endormirait tout le monde. Le fait de
faire des erreurs, ça fait qu'on a des
aspérités, quoi. Et donc, on peut se on
peut se parler quoi. Bah, ça c'est
typiquement de la robustesse construite
contre la performance. Donc en fait ce
ce chemin il est il est positif parce
qu'on se on se relie à qui on est
vraiment quoi.
Comment on fait pour créer du relief
entre vous et les et et les politiques ?
Alors ben moi je crois beaucoup aux
locaux he quand même et aussi il y a
quelques personnes en fait c'est voilà
c'est les zones pathogènes. Voilà faut
faut faut identifier les zones
pathogènes. Donc dans dans des projets,
il y a toujours des zones dans
lesquelles ça sert à rien de mettre de
l'énergie parce que on est face à un mur
hein. Donc c'est pas la peine de faire
un sitting devant le genre prendre Total
ou Chell ou Exon quoi
ou l'Assemblée nationale. Ouais ça va
pas servir à grandchose par contre il y
a et ça et c'est peut-être pas
quel regard pardon je peux vous couper
bien sûr bien sûr. Euh quel regard vous
portez par exemple à ceux qui font des
sitings lors de l'assemblée euh générale
de
général ils ils ont leur rôle. C'estàd
que ça maintient la veilleuse quoi. Donc
c'est c'est utile mais on sait que ça ne
va pas transformer. Ça permet de mettre
le sujet euh médiatiquement. Euh ça peut
dire que bah il est là, il y a des gens
qui s'y intéressent. Donc c'est utile
mais ce n'est pas transformateur. Ce qui
est transformateur
c'est plutôt d'aller voir le
l'interstice qui se situe entre les
oiseaux qui sont à la marge donc ont
déjà compris le monde de leur busesse et
ceux qui sont au cœur du système qui
vont jamais changer. Et donc c'est ce
moment en fait les gens qui sont dans le
trouble qui sont un peu qui qui
commencent à refouler des choses qui
sont dans un déniis de moins en moins
assumé quoi. Donc là c'est là qu'il faut
travailler quoi. C'est c'est là qu'en
fait on accélère la contamination du
cœur.
Vous avez jamais interagi avec un
sociopathe vous ?
Alors je peut-être mais j'en sais rien.
J'ai pas reconnu en tout cas
dans le déniusqu'au bout.
Ah dans le déni jusqu'au bout. Je suis
pas je sais pas je sais pas si ça existe
vraiment à vra dire parce que même si on
prend Donald Trump par exemple chaque
fois qu'il parle de du réchauffement
climatique du dérèglement climatique en
disant que ça n'existe pas on a vraiment
l'impression de quelqu'un qui refoule
hein à mon avis il a très peur hein du
du réchauffement climatique et en fait
c'est c'est juste qu'il arrête pas d'en
parler pour exorciser sa peur quoi. Donc
je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait beaucoup de
gens qui soient vraiment dans le déni
dans un déni de plombe quoi. Mais j'en
sais rien j'ai pas fait de d'études.
Vous êtes en train de me faire perdre
mon fil. Euh, je vais poser une question
internet d'ailleurs. Euh, on va prendre
au hasard. Bonjour. En l'état de la
nature la plus violent
à l'état de nature le plus violent gagne
dans notre société, on voudrait que ce
soit celui du cocrit.
Un autre, désolé. On reprend une autre.
Alors quand même, j'ai quand même sur la
première partie hein. Dans la nature,
c'est pas le plus violent. Alors celui
qui collabore le plus qui gagne, c'est
contre nature non point d'interrogation.
Alors sémantique collaboration c'est pas
comme la coopération hein. La
collaboration c'est chacun
voilà et robustesse. Voilà, c'est pas du
tout pareil. Un petit un petit point
sémantique, c'est vrai que c'est pas ça
peut être utile. Donc la la
collaboration c'est chacun avance sur
son projet individuel et on espère que
la somme des succès individuels fait un
succès collectif. Donc ça c'est le
gagnant gagnant où il y a toujours
quelqu'un qui perd. Donc la
collaboration c'est de la compétition
qui ne dit pas son nom. La coopération
c'est l'objectif commun qu'il emporte
sur les objectifs individuels. Donc dans
une coopération il faut aller parfois
contre son objectif individuel pour
atteindre l'objectif commun. Donc c'est
une contreperformance individuelle au
service de la robustesse du groupe. Et
alors du coup donc si on remplace
collaboration par coopération
donc la question c'était du coup j'ai
perdu la question c'est dans Ouais
à l'état de nature le plus violent qui
gagne dans notre société on voudrait que
ce soit pardon que ce soit celui qui
collabore le plus qui gagne.
Ouais ouais
désolé pour l'architecture de la phrase.
C'est contre nature. Non point
interrogation. Alors, dans la nature,
c'est très simple, il y a compétition et
coopération. Les deux sont là. Le jeu,
le type de jeu collectif, hein,
compétition ou coopération dépend au
premier ordre de la quantité de
ressources dans le milieu. Dans un
milieu qui est riche en ressources, qui
est stable, les êtres vivants font de la
compétition. Dans un monde qui est
pauvre à ressources et qui est
fluctuant, les êtres vivants font de la
coopération. Et ça peut être vrai, c'est
les mêmes, hein. Les mêmes êtres
vivants, on les place dans des
différents milieux. Donc c'est des
levures en tube essai, c'est des
abeilles dans une ruche, c'est les
cellules de votre corps, c'est vraiment
tout hein, les manchud sur la banquise,
c'est le milieu qui au premier ordre va
déterminer le type de jeu collectif. Et
vous avez déjà joué en collectif avec
des sociopathes ?
Non, ça j'ai pas fait.
Oui, mais il y en a. Oui, bien sûr. Mais
quand je regarde la géopolitique
mondiale, il y a que des sociopathes
partout. Bien sûr. Ah ben oui, mais
parce qu'on est dans un monde de la
performance qui sélectionne les
sociopathes. En fait, c'est ça, c'est
qu'en fait vu qu'on est dans un monde
d'abondance, ceux qui réussissent ce
sont les ultra performants. Donc les
ultra compétiteurs,
donc les ultra violents.
Les ultra violents, exactement. Donc
c'est eux qui gagnent. Mais dans un
monde fluent, c'est eux qui vont perdre
parce qu'en fait, ils se sont enferrés
dans une voie étroite. Ils seront
incapables de se remettre en cause et
donc ils vont pas se rendre compte
qu'ils sont à côté de la plaque, quoi.
Donc c'est moi, c'est pour ça que je
suis assez optimiste, hein. En fait, il
y aura pas le choix. Et et enfin là,
c'est presque le biologiste qui parle.
Je comprends bien que une société
humaine, c'est pas une société de
fourmis, hein. J'ai bien compris he
qu'il y a des jeux de pouvoir et cetera.
Donc il y a tout l'aspect social,
politique, je veux pas dépolitiser non
plus le discours, mais il faut
comprendre que ça c'est en nous. Et donc
dans un monde qui devient fluctuant en
pénurie chronique de ressources, ce
seront les coopérateurs qui vont s'en
mieux s'en sortir. Et alors, on peut
même imaginer, alors là, je vais prendre
une autre analogie, c'est l'arbre, hein.
L'arbre euh comment se comment fait-il ?
qui coopère beaucoup l'arbre alors qu'en
fait il a beaucoup de ressources dans
son tron. Il a énormément de ressources
sucrées, hein. Donc comment fait-il pour
être dans l'abondance tout en faisant de
la coopération ? Alors c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire, c'est que l'arbre en
fait il a des stocks masqués dans son
tron. Il a des stocks qu'ilutilisent
jamais. Et donc en fait il est en état
de pénurie relative, en tout cas de pas
de surabondance. Il a juste ce qu'il
faut donc pour vivre. Donc du coup il
fait plutôt de la coopération et en fait
le jour où il y a un gros accident la
foudre qui tombe qui le décapite quoi.
Stress hydrique.
Stress hydrique énorme. Voilà. mais
vraiment un gros stress hein. Là du coup
il va taper dans son stock stratégique,
refaire des branches, refaire des
bourgeons et avec ça, il va refaire des
la photosynthèse et réalimenter ses
stocks stratégiques. Et c'est la
première chose qu'il va faire les stocks
stratégiques qui l'utilisent jamais.
Donc en fait c'est on peut penser que
dans le monde qui vient pour faire des
coopérateurs, il faudra vraiment penser
au concept de stock masqué. C'est qu'en
fait on a des stocks, c'est un filet de
sécurité mais dans lequel on ne tape
pas. Alors qu'aujourd'hui, on est plutôt
à épuiser le pétrole jusqu'à la dernière
goutte. Donc on utilise tous nos stocks,
on on déstocke quoi. Voilà, on déstock
et donc on est dans l'abondance, dans la
compétition, dans la violence. Le monde
qui vient vu qu'on aura plus accès à
tous ces stocks parce que ça sera plus
acceptable, parce qu'il y aura trop de
pollution et voilà, on va plutôt aller
vers de la coopération et donc ça sera à
nous d'inventer des stocks masqués quoi.
Enfin, je c'est une façon de voir hein.
Je vous dis bien bon courage.
Euh question internet. Bonsoir. Le
métier de chercheur en biologie, ultra
dépendant de la mondialisation pour son
exercice en terme de matériel, de
consommable, de technologie, a-t-il un
avenir dans le monde qui vient ?
Bien sûr. Alors, c'est là aussi il faut
tout réinventer, c'est qu'en fait dans
le monde, en effet dans le monde actuel,
un chercheur il est soumis à des
indicateurs de performance. Moi, j'ai un
facteur H qui mesure ma performance. Je
publie dans des articles qui ont des
facteurs d'impact. Il y a des
indicateurs de performance à tous les
rangs, le classement de Shanga et
cetera. Donc en fait bah en effet et ça
c'est très contreproductif hein, ça
pousse à publier trop vite, ça pousse à
la fraude scientifique et cetera. Donc
du coup bah dans le monde fluctuant, un
chercheur ce sera d'abord quelqu'un qui
fait des recherches participatives, des
sciences citoyennes. Donc en fait ça
veut dire que avec les citoyens on va
poser des questions. En fait le rôle de
l'interaction avec les citoyens, ça va
être d'abord de questionner la question.
Donc il s'arrê il s'agit pas de
d'arrêter la recherche, il s'agit plutôt
de resituer la recherche, de faire les
connaissances situées, de d'hybrider
connaissance, on va dire universelle et
connaissance située. Et donc en fait
c'est là aussi c'est très intéressant
pour un chercheur, c'est que pour un
biologiste comme moi qui fait de la
biologie végétale, plutôt que de
regarder des plantes en système hyper
contrôlé avec des néons, avec une
température contrôlée tout ça, on va
plutôt mettre des mélanges de plantes
avec des environnements fluctuants. Donc
alors en terme de statistique tout ça,
la complexité elle est énorme mais au
moins il y a des vrais problèmes
mathématiques de modélisation
informatique hyper intéressant quoi. Et
en plus enfin c'est surtout en fait
c'est que ça ça reproduit vraiment ce
que c'est un vrai écosystème. Est-ce que
ça reproduit vraiment ce que c'est qu'un
vrai agrosystème en agroécologie ? Parce
que là aujourd'hui dans les labos de
recherche en biologie végétale
finalement on fait des systèmes hyper
contrôlés pour soutenir la monoculture
finalement indirectement. Donc ça sera
nettement plus joyeux plus tard. On va
faire de la recherche qui sera adaptée à
un monde biodivers quoi.
Question internet, je suis désolé, c'est
un vrai pavé. Bon, on va se la faire
quand même.
J'ai 27 ans et je travaille sur les
questions d'adaptation au changement
climatique dans le domaine de la
conservation de la biodiversité. Depuis
plusieurs années, je constate que les
personnes en charge, entre parenthèses
techniciens, conservateurs, écologues,
biologistes, ainsi que certains
collègues spécialistes spécialisés dans
cette thématique éprouvent encore des
difficultés à intégrer le bouleversement
en cours et entre guillemets à agir en
conséquence. L'invité est-il également
confronté à cette réalité ? Si l'idée de
conservation de la biodiversité
disparaît, quel sera-t-il qu'en
sera-t-il des espèces protégées ? Ils
disparaîtront également et qu'elle
viendra-t-il des ces zones naturelles
pour interrogation selon lui ? Alors en
effet, le monde de la recherche, on
pourrait penser que c'est euh très en
avance, hein, euh sur le le changement.
C'est tout le contraire, hein. Euh parce
qu'en fait des personnes éduquées sont
capables d'argumenter et donc les
premières personnes qu'elles
convainquent, c'est elles-même. Et donc
en fait, c'est un des milieux les plus
conservateurs qui existe. Et donc en
fait, c'est pour ça qu'on a des élèves
ingénieurs déserteurs parce qu'ils sont
confrontés à des enseignants chercheurs
qui souvent n'ont pas compris à quel
point on vivait un basculement
important. pas tous hein, il y a
toujours des exceptions hein, mais quand
même voilà, il y a il y a un vrai
problème de au niveau de l'enseignement.
Alors sur la biodiversité euh là aussi
il faut dire les choses euh dans la
question socio-écologique, ce qui domine
c'est le climat hein et voir même le CO2
hein. Donc ça c'est de la performance
hein. On a réduit toute la complexité
socio-écologique à une molécule hein. Le
CO2
c'est une aberration.
C'est une aberration totale. En fait du
coup ce qui se passe c'est que les
solutions qu'on apporte c'est pour
réduire la quantité de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère. Donc cet été en Islande on
a construit la première grande usine de
capture direct du CO2. Donc un enfant de
5 ans comprendrait que ça n'a aucun sens
hein. C'est beaucoup d'énergie, beaucoup
de métaux et c'est une opération
financière. Ça permet à d'autres
entreprises, voilà, d'acheter des côtats
à carbone pour continuer à polluer. Donc
c'est on a privatisé le CO2. Donc en
fait en fait quand on apporte des
solutions à la quantité de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère, on aggrave la pénurie de
ressources, on aggrave les pollutions
globales et on aggrave l'effondrement de
la biodiversité. Donc le climat c'est le
pire levier. Il faut pas commencer par
le climat. Il faut commencer vous faire
des amis vous. Non. Ah mais non mais
c'est mais mais ça c'est pragmatique. Il
faut commencer par la biodiversité.
Notre performance fait une guerre à la
vie. Là je reprends la phrase d'Arthur
Keller. C'est une guerre à la vie. Donc
si on fait une guerre à la vie, il faut
commencer par la biodiversité. Et donc
la biodiversité c'est tout simple hein,
c'est ça coûte rien. Faut se met des
graines. On peut le faire à toutes les
échelles, sur son balcon dans un jardin.
À l'échelle mondiale bah c'est
l'agriculture le premier levier. Pour
l'agriculture on a à peu près toutes les
techniques agroforesterie, agroécologie,
permaculture, jardin créole comme je
disais. Donc en fait, on a on a tous les
leviers et quand on quand on prend soin
de la biodiversité, c'est positif pour
le climat, c'est positif pour les
pollutions globales et c'est positif
pour les pénories de ressources. Donc en
fait c'est très simple. La biodiversité
c'est le levier le plus systémique. Il
faut commencer par biodiversité. En plus
ça coûte moins cher et on a toutes les
techniques. Donc c'est pas la peine.
C'est pas une question de RD hein, c'est
c'est vraiment une question culturelle.
Il faut commencer à se reconnecter à la
vie. Voilà.
Ah bah bien du courage. Question
internet. Connaissez-vous le livre
d'Albert Jacard de 1981 Les loges de la
différence, la génétique et les hommes ?
Dans cet ouvrage, Jacar critique les
notions de compétition et
d'individualisme, affirmant que la
survie et le progrès de l'humanité
repose davantage sur la coopération et
la complémentarité entre les individus.
Il développe des idées sur de
l'importance sur l'importance de la
solidarité et la collaboration dans une
société plutôt que la rivalité. Je mets
une parenthèse, arrêtez de me faire des
questions comme ça.
Oui. Bah bien sûr, en fait bah c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure, on est en
train de basculer de l'abondance
matérielle à l'abondance des
interactions. Et ben donc c'est la
coopération. Et en fait c'est c'est ça
qui est très joyeux hein quand même.
J'aurais mettre un peu de joie là parce
que je comprends le le cidisme et tout
ça. On vit dans un monde compliqué et il
y a des scénarios noirs qui se sont
devant nous. Mais il y a aussi ce
basculement fondamental. On s'est fait
piéger dans un dans une idée du bonheur
qui est la bonheur de l'abondance
matérielle. Enfin, plein de gens le
disent he ça. Donc là, on va rentrer
dans un monde où le bonheur va être
défini par nos interactions. Et ben,
c'est quand même nettement plus joyeux
et c'est plus c'est plus vivant, c'est
plus humain, quoi. C'est c'est là là
c'est la biologie positive quoi. Mais la
biologie bien comprise hein, poste
Darwin mal compris, quoi.
On va avoir le bonheur de ressentir un
estomac plein.
Oui. Non mais je comprends. Alors c'est
pas je suis pas en train de prêcher pour
la pénurie hein. C'est je dis juste
queen fait là on est dans la situation
de surabondance. C'est quand il y a
surabondance, hein, qu'on fait la
guerre, qu'on fait des la compétition et
de la violence, on peut trouver un juste
milieu quand même hein. En fait, c'est
ce que font les écosystèmes. Ils sont
pas tout le temps dans l'abondance. En
fait, l'hiver, par exemple, c'est une
période de pénurie euh pour les êtres
vivants, enfin région tempéré, mais ils
ont trouvé la solution, hein. Ils
hibernent et puis ils se réveillent au
printemps. Bon bah, donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a des moments d'abondance, il y
a des moments où il y a moins
d'abondance, mais c'est pas comme si euh
c'était la pénurie euh à jamais quoi.
Voilà, c'est ça va fluctuer plus quoi.
Euh peut-être qu'on aura pas accès à
tous les biens de consommation en
permanence livré le jour même si besoin,
quoi. Ça et c'est pas un gros regret
quand même.
On a parlé un peu du futur ou de des des
ébauches ou des aates de système
politique émergent. Je vais vous poser
une autre question. Est-ce que vous avez
modélisé plus le côté humain ? Est-ce
qu'on sera plus dans une polygamie, une
polyandrie, une poly quoi ? Ah ben alors
c'est euh c'est la fin du patriarcat
hein très clairement euh le enfin euh
enfin c'est la fin je le dis trop à la
serpe hein. Là faudra nuancer tout ce
que je dis hein parce que c'est quand
même je le dis beaucoup trop à la serppe
c'est un peu le rythme hein. Mais mais
en effet le patriarcat c'est quand même
euh des valeurs de performance hein.
Enfin c'est c'est ça qui qui est mis en
avant dans le patriarcat. On peut être
un homme et ne pas être dans le
patriarcat. Enfin, je faut aussi séparer
les deux choses. Et donc, en fait, le
monde qui vient, c'est plutôt un monde
où on va respecter les les différentes
valeurs quoi. On aura besoin de temps en
temps d'être dans la compétition, mais
c'est plutôt la coopération qui va
dominer et du coup, ben ce sera
certainement un tout petit peu plus
écoéministe quoi.
Question internet,
comment peut-on être aussi critique
envers les extractivistes et recevoir un
prix Schlumberger ? Ah oui,
un des plus acteurs un des acteurs
pétroliers les plus grands acteurs
pétroliers du monde.
Ouais. Ouais. Alors en effet,
Schlumerger donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
qui a développé des sondes pour
identifier les les champs pétrolifères.
Alors le le prix he c'est pas
Schlouberger hein, c'est la fondation
pour l'éducation et la recherche mais en
effet qui a été financée au départ par
Schumberger. Aujourd'h maintenant c'est
déconnecté he quand même mais alors le
lien si quand même parce que c'est une
fondation qui est la fondation des tres
et qui fait un super travail. euh de
lien entre art et science. C'est une des
rares fondations qui fait un super
travail de fond. Et alors, il y a aussi
un autre lien. Moi étant à l'Institut
Michel Ser, Michel Ser était un fidèle
de cette fondation et donc il y a plein
de liens dans la durée avec la pensée de
de Michel Ser. Donc j'assume totalement
ce prixl. Enfin, je suis j'étais heureux
de de l'avoir en fait.
Question internet. Où et comment euh
est-ce que cette notion de robustesse
vous est apparue ?
Où ? Comment ? Bah, c'est un peu ce que
je disais, c'est dans mon labo
finalement. C'est enfin là où alors
encore avant c'est bon c'est en
discutant avec les collègues hein je
peux penser à risque Bouaou enfin des
des Dorota Koska enfin des des tas de
collègues qui m'ont accompagné dans dans
toutes ces années mais c'est venu
progressivement en fait mais si je
devais remonter vraiment plus loin en
fait moi quand j'étais au collège donc
là je vais vraiment remonter très loin
je je savais que je voulais faire de la
biologie je savais que ça m'intéressait
le vivant les plantes même je savais que
je voulais travailler sur les plantes
mais j'aimais pas la façon dont on
m'enseigner la biologie parce que
c'était en silo quoi. C'était un jour on
apprenait le cœur la semaine suivante
c'était la photosynthèse. Enfin, ça se
parlait pas quoi.
Stomates,
les stomates, voilà tout ça quoi. Donc
c'était tout un peu mélangé quoi. Et à
un moment en fait, on se rend compte que
tout ça se parle quoi. Et là, en fait,
on se reconnecte à pourquoi on veut
faire de la biologie. En fait, c'est la
la partie systémique hein qui qui me qui
m'a plu. Et donc, quand on fait de la
systémique, ben la robustesse c'est le
cœur, hein, finalement. C'est en fait la
robusesse, c'est la porte d'entrée dans
la pensée systémique. Finalement quand
on fait de la robusesse, on est obligé
d'avoir une vision beaucoup plus large
des choses et de mettre les interactions
avant les éléments.
Il faudrait que vous essayez de faire un
to auprès de nos services de
renseignement. Je pense qu'il y a des
choses à apprendre chez vous en terme de
robustesse. Question internet. Comment
s'informe-t-il et sur quelle plateforme
peut-on le suivre ?
Alors, il y a plein de choses. Il y a
institutichelser.fr. On a pas mal de
ressources là-dessus. J'ai écrit des
bouquins aussi. Il y a le petit tracte
Galimar là, antidote occulte de la
performance qu'on peut trouver
d'ailleurs en PDF. Donc voilà, enfin
faut l'acheter une fois et puis après
c'est assez facile à partager. J'aurais
peut-être pas trop le lire mais euh il y
a au Jacob aussi la troisème boîte du
vivant. Voilà donc là c'est beaucoup
plus en en profondeur 300 pages 500
références euh de l'incohérence aussi.
Enfin, je pas vous faire a des bouquins.
C'est intéressant ce que vous avez dit
en début de phrase. Euh la propriété.
Oui. Ah bah oui. Bah voilà, c'est alors
exactement donc le on est en train aussi
de basculer de l'économie propriétaire à
l'économie de l'usage, du partage, de la
fonctionnalité. Et ce qui là aussi c'est
un exemple parfait pour montrer la
contamination des marges vers les vers
le cœur. Euh typiquement un atelier de
réparation il y a 20 ans, c'était un
atelier de réparation de vélo en ville
quoi. Et ben aujourd'hui, il n'y a plus
une seule entreprise qui ne se pose pas
la question de la réparabilité de ces
produits. Quand on fait du réparable, ça
veut dire qu'on fait du service. Et
alors il arrive un moment où on se dit
"Bah en fait, je vais juste mettre en
fait je vais les gens ne seront plus
propriétaires de leur bien, on va juste
les réparer, les échanger." Donc c'est
Mobion par exemple qui fait des ves pas
voilà des montables réparables et qui et
dont on n'est pas propriétaire et c'est
même culturellement et donc là ça ça
répond aussi à la question des humains.
Euh alors je prends un exemple français
hein les jeunes français dans les années
80 leur liberté c'était d'avoir leur
voiture hein. Enfin je caricature he
c'était d'avoir un micro et une radio ou
ouais aussi. Oui bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr. Mais aussi souvent d'avoir une
voiture. Bah aujourd'hui avoir une
voiture ou mob voilà. Bah aujourd'hui
avoir une voiture c'est une charge
surtout ça coûte trop cher. Il faut le
parking, il faut la carte grise, enfin
c'est c'est voilà ça embête quoi. Donc
covoiturage, cities, voiture partagé
location et cetera. En fait le le
rapport à la propriété est en train de
changer. C'est c'est la fameuse phrase
digitale. Si si c'est gratuit, tu es le
produit. Euh bah ça ça dit tout quoi.
C'est en fait on est on a un regard
beaucoup plus critique sur la propriété
aujourd'hui quand
j'en profite pour vous dire et dire à la
communauté financez-nous parce que
c'estw c'est pas si gratuit que ça.
C'est la communauté qui finance nos
émissions, notre travail de fond sur du
long terme. Donc hésitez passer sur
notre tip, on a vraiment besoin.
Question internet en mode avocat du
diable. Les plus robustes survivent face
aux plus performants.
C'est votre citation. Dans quelle
catégorie classe-t-il le seigneur de
guerre ? sans l'État, sans état avec sa
petite armée pour contraindre des
communautés démocratiques et
écologistes,
une performance ou un robuste. Et je
continue la deuxième question. Quel taux
de survie de communauté d'entraide des
solidaires écologiques
qui n'aurait pas de performance entre
guillemets manque de productivité
agricole et de gestion financière pour
exploiter un terrain de manière
productive ?
Ouais. Alors là, je renvoie à la
gouvernance des biens communs de
d'inorrom. C'est très pratique parce que
c'est donc ils ont fait une métaanalyse
donc les prix Nobel d'économie 2009, une
des rares qui mérite vraiment son prix
Nobel une métaanalyse de commun qui sont
restés communs pendant des siècles. Donc
en gros, c'est des collectifs d'humains
qui ont une ressource précieuse
partagée. Et ce qu'ils ont trouvé toute
cette école là, c'est qu'il fallait
suivre h principes. Et si on suit h des
huit principes, alors le commun reste
commun pendant des siècles. Donc ça ça
veut dire que ça a traversé les famines,
les épidémies, les guerres. Donc c'est
un vrai test. Donc c'est des risières,
c'est des parcelles de haute montagne,
c'est des acquif, enfin c'est tout ça,
c'est des ressources comme ça. Et donc
ça c'est ça c'est vraiment une clé
importante et en fait on se rend compte
que pour que ça dure, c'est pas juste
qu'il y ait une ressource en commun, il
faut faire commun. Le verbe important
c'est fairein. Donc en fait il faut
vraiment avoir des règles du de la
gestion du commun. Donc la gouvernance
des biens communs quoi. Et ben en fait
c'est donc ça veut dire que le seigneur
de guerre n'est pas un commun. Donc en
fait, il va être très fragile. Il peut
être ça peut être flamboyant pendant une
courte période mais c'est un feu de
paille hein. Alors que le coma ça dure
des siècles, hein. Je Il y a pas de
seigneur de guerre qui dure des siècles.
Question euh internet. Dans un monde de
pénurie, hm hm,
ce n'est pas celui qui sait mieux capter
et manipuler la ressource à son profit
qui réussit dans l'interrogation ?
Non, parce qu'en fait, il épise de la
ressource. Donc toute façon, il se
suicide lui-même, hein. C'est qu'en
fait, il peut avoir un intérêt à court
terme. C'est que à court terme, il va
peut-être suivre un peu plus que les
autres, mais en fait, il va quand même
il va quand même c'est faut penser à
quelqu'un qui est sur un bateau et qui
mangerait tous les biscuits du gâteau
quoi, du bateau. Bah, en fait, oui, il
va il va surv un peu plus que les
voisins mais il va être tout seul et à
un moment, il va avoir besoin des autres
pour arrimer son bateau pour ramer un
peu plus vite ou je sais pas quoi. Donc
en fait, il va se suicider quand même
quoi.
Question internet. À quoi ressemblerait
un capitalisme entre guillemets patché
avec ces découvertes inspirées de la
nature ?
Ouais bah ça sera un capitalisme quand
même très différent hein. Bah ce serait
déjà un capitalisme qui a un lien très
distant à la propriété. Alors
capitalisme un capitat c'est la tête de
bétail hein quand même. Donc il y a un
lien très fort à la propriété. Donc en
fait il faudrait certainement l'appeler
autre chose que du capitalisme très
clairement.
Alors question euh qu'on a déjà posé
mais on va la reposer. Robustesse ou
résilience ? C'est quoi la différence ?
Oui oui oui. Alors une grosse différence
donc la résilience il y a donc la
résilience ça vient de la la science des
matériaux. Un matériau résilient c'est
un matériau qui se déforme et qui
revient à son état initial donc
encaisser les chocs.
Après, ça s'est transformé en résilience
psychologique. Donc je tombe après un
traumatisme et puis je me relève. Donc
et voilà. Donc ça ça peut marcher dans
des contextes médicaux très
particuliers. Quand on l'étend à tout le
monde socio-économique, là ça devient
toxique, ça devient une incitation à
tomber pour se relever. L'exemple
typique he c'est la politique nationale
de la résilience au Japon. Donc ça c'est
Thierry Ribau qui parle dans contre la
résilience. Euh la politique nationale
de la résilience au Japon après
Fukushima, c'est pour ne pas avoir peur
des radiations, il faut s'exposer.
Donc on voit bien euh l'arnaque de la
résilience là quand même hein. Euh donc
en fait la résilience c'est devenu une
arnaque. Donc en fait la résilience en
gros c'est une trajectoire. On tombe et
on se relève. La robustesse c'est on
augmente les bornes, on élargit les
bornes pour autoriser n'importe quelle
trajectoire, y compris la trajectoire
résiliente. Mais si on tombe, on est sûr
de se relever, quoi. C'est ça la
différence. Donc faut commencer par la
robustesse. He c'est ce que je dis
souvent. La robustesse, c'est
pragmatique dans un monde fluctuant.
Faut être robuste et c'est aussi une
méthode. C'est le premier critère de tri
dans les solutions. Faut qu'elle soit
robuste quoi.
Bonjour. Question internet. Bonjour. Il
y a beaucoup de question internet
aujourd'hui. Bonjour. Où se trouve la
place de la spiritualité dans vos propos
?
Pour le moment, les modèles existants
datent un peu.
Ouais. Oui, bien sûr. Alors le bah alors
c'est deux questions un peu différentes,
hein. Mais sur le la spiritualité en
fait. Alors si on pense religion par
exemple hechamama,
la patchaama par exemple, voilà,
animisme et tout ça, en fait ce qui
relie toutes ces toutes ces
spiritualités, c'est du lien en fait.
C'est pas du pognon.
Alors c'est devenu ça mais exactement.
Alors, c'est pouvoir et puissance. He
donc si on pense que une religion au
sens premier du terme, c'est relié,
c'est des interactions, c'est de la
pensée systémique. On met des éléments
interaction, ça se lit entre eux et ça
crée quelque chose. Donc ça crée Dieu
quoi. Dieu c'est une propriété émergente
de l'interaction des humains. Donc ça
c'est de la puissance parce qu'en fait
on a une ombrelle commune qui nous
rassemble et qui se propage et qui se
déploie. Donc ça quand en gros quand ça
c'est de la puissance et quand par
contre on parle au nom de Dieu là on est
dans le pouvoir donc là c'est dans
l'autre sens et là c'est beaucoup plus
toxique évidemment
voilà exactement donc du coup bah c'est
Ouais imparable quoi. Donc il y a les
deux quoi. Voilà
on est mal barré hein. Euh donc la
spiritualisé on a traité euh alors
question un peu
vous cré du diable. Robustesse ou
antifragilité ?
Et ben pareil. Alors, antiragilité,
c'est une version un peu boostée de la
résilience, hein. C'est qu'en fait, on
tombe et quand on se relève, on va un
peu un cran plus haut. Donc, c'est par
exemple, quand on se casse un os, on se
fait une fracture et quand il se remet,
l'os, il est plus costaud qu'avant. Il
est plus solide qu'avant. Mais
il est plus faible aux deux extrémités,
hein.
Oui. Oua, il y a d'autres problèmes,
bien sûr, bien sûr. Mais mais euh
localement, en tout cas, il est plus
rigide. Donc, du coup là, c'est de
l'antifragilité. Alors c'est pareil,
l'antifragilité c'est comme la
résilience, c'est devenu une incitation
à tomber pour être encore plus fort
après. Donc c'est de nouveau de la
sélection darwinienne mal comprise quoi.
La la robustesse encore une fois c'est
autre chose. C'est on élargit les bornes
pour autoriser n'importe quelle
trajectoire.
Bonjour l'invité connaît-il François
Rodier et sa thèse sur la
thermodynamique de l'évolution ?
Non pas bien. J'en ai déjà entendu
parler mais j'ai pas creusé donc je vais
pas dire de bêtises.
Euh euh on va arrêter les questions
internet. On va reprendre un peu notre
interview euh tranquillement.
Euh qu'est-ce qui a été le plus dur pour
vous euh en terme de
d'anticipation ? a été voir le choc sur
notre société, c'est-à-dire vos copains
d'école, vos amis, vos voisins, vos amis
de la région
et et les voir en fait est exposé à ça
sans comprendre, sans anticiper, sans
changer ou c'est vous avez été égoïste
en disant voilà bon ils sont très panés,
on va les laisser dans leur monde et
voilà, tant pis.
Alors c'est mar parce que j'ai une autre
vision. Ouais, en fait euh j'ai tendance
à voir les le pas qui avance. Donc on
peut être très loin, on est tous à des
stades différents de de la bascule hein
euh très clairement, mais on est tous en
mouvement quand même. Alors il y en a
qui sont en mouvement dans l'ultra
performance, donc là qui vraiment se
plantent, mais il y en a beaucoup qui
font un pas. Euh alors c'est je suis pas
en train de dire la politique des des
petits pas, c'est pas ça que je suis en
train de dire mais c'est reconnaître qu'
il y a du jeu dans les rouages de plus
en plus hein. Euh en fait bah l'exemple
typique c'est le Covid he quand même
hein. En 2019 on était enfin quand je
dis on hein c'est les entreprises les
collectivités locales et cetera était
encore avec des plans, des stratégies
tout ça.
Il y avait pas autre plan il y avait
aucun stratégie.
Il courait comme des poulets sans tête
ils interdisaient au aux formations de
vag ça la stratégie finalement c'est de
rien chang. Voilà, ça c'est en fait
c'est la stratégie, on continue comme
avant quoi. Et euh et le Covid a dit
"Bah non, en fait c'est pas possible,
c'est un vrai moment d'arrêt." C'est en
fait c'est ça a semé des graines quand
même hein, parce que d'un seul coup, on
se dit "Bah oui, en fait euh pourquoi je
fais des business plans ? Pourquoi je
fais des plans pour ma commit euh
ou bah alors oui alors là c'est un ça
peut être dangereux parce que en fait ça
lien social. Bah pour alors c'est la
façon la plus vertueuse de faire du
collectif par la redistribution, c'est
la cotisation parce que c'est
indépendant de ce qu'on produit. Donc ça
c'est on avance finalement la donc c'est
normal hein enf c'est qu'on doit faire
Bernard Friot en parle mieux que moi.
Faut d'abord cotiser mais l'impôt faute
de mieux c'est quand même pas mal quoi.
C'est quand même en fait on délègue à
une une structure plus transversale la
redistribution. La la le la le
contreemodèle, c'est la philanthropie
qui est euh problématique parce qu'en
fait qui décide enfin quand Bill Gates
décide de d'éradiquer le le sida en
Afrique, c'est une distorsion de la
santé, des systèmes de santé quand même
hein. Ça c'était montré par The Land 7
et compagnie. Enfin, il y a plein
d'articles là-dessus,
pas la malaria. Alors, il y avait aussi
le SID, il y en a eu plein, il y en a eu
plusieurs donc mais à chaque fois c'est
quelqu'un qui met beaucoup d'argent dans
un coin. Du coup, bah les infirmiers,
les infirmières veulent travailler sur
ce sujet là et du coup il travaille plus
sur l' quoi. Donc c'est une distorsion
très claire du système. Donc à la
philanthropie très dangereux quoi. Enfin
la philopie ça peut être très bien si
c'est bien fait mais c'est si on ne fait
que de la philanthropie et qu'il y a
plus d'impôts. Très compliqué quand
même. C'est donc moi je suis assez pro
impôt en fait.
Est-ce qu'on Est-ce que vous je peux
vous demander ce que vous votez ? Moi,
je suis plutôt à gauche. Ouais, plutôt à
gauche écolo quoi.
Quel regarder critique vous portez sur
la gauche écolo ? Ben alors euh bon
alors ben c'est bon il y a pas al je je
je vais pas trop le tirer dans les
pattes parce qu'ils sont quand même dans
dans une
c'est un petit peu euh bon et je pense
quand même que c'est euh des parties qui
ont mieux compris euh ce qui se passait
que d'autres euh qui ont en tout cas euh
vu que bah le tissu social euh c'est
plutôt porté par la gauche, la question
de l'équité c'est plutôt portée par la
gauche. La question socio-écologique
plutôt par les écolos. Enfin, je il y a
quand même ce ce champ-là a compris des
choses. Après, il y a des il y a des il
y a des manquements quoi. Bah la la
gauche socialiste quand elle parle dans
le social libéral là comme François
Hollande, bon on est dans la
schizophrénie totale. Quand les écolos
ou certains écolos disent que on va
faire de la douceur, bah ça ça marche
pas non plus parce que les gens vivent
des choses très violentes en ce moment.
Donc en fait bah bon, je remettre ma
robustesse sur la table. Il me semble
que la robustesse, ça permettrait de
mettre pas mal de monde d'accord, y
compris d'ailleurs à droite ou un peu
partout au centre aussi quoi. C'est
qu'en fait cette question de la
robustesse c'est pragmatique ça en fait
plutôt que de sortir enf on peut sortir
des idéologies droite gauche ce que
disait Bruno Latour maintenant c'est
terrestre extraterrestre quoi. Le nouvel
axe c'est plus gauche droite quoi. C'est
extrrestre extraterrestre et le le quand
on est terrestre ça veut dire qu'on a
endossé le fait scientifique le monde
fluctuant et donc la robustesse c'est
encore une fois le premier critère de
tri pour développer des politiques
locales des lois et cetera quoi. C'est
ça va être la question qu'on va se poser
au 21e siècle.
Vous vouliez évoquer le nucléaire ?
Ouais. Alors bah sur le nucléaire donc
j'ai déjà un peu démonter la fusion
nucléaire parce que c'est en fait c'est
l'objectif qui est mauvais hein. C'est
même pas la technique. C'est même pas la
peine de passer une seconde sur la
technique hein tout ça. Enfin donc là je
passe sur la fusion et sur le nucléaire.
Alors c'est là où on va diverger. Donc
Jean-Marc Jeanco ici hein. J'admire tout
le travail pédagogique il a vraiment mis
le sujet sur la table. Donc voilà je
vais mettre ça en facteur commun. Mais
sur le nucléaire, on n pas vraiment
d'accord hein. Une centrale nucléaire
dans un monde fluctuant.
Vous voulez pas d'amortisseur vous ?
Non. Ben non, parce que un un non une
centrale nucléaire mais c'est même pas
une question énergétique petit fouet là
pour Non
non c'est en fait une centrale nucléaire
dans un monde fluctuant c'est une bombe
sale. C'est aporidja quoi. On ne on va
pas construire des nouvelles central
nucléaires. C'est c'est des points de
faiblesse énormes.
Fukunima
non Zaporijja. Je parle vraiment de
Zaporij. C'est dans un monde fluctuant
en Ukraine. Voilà, c'est qu'en fait une
centrale nucléaire ça ne marche que si
le pays est en paix.
Et dans un monde fluctuant, c'est
absolument pas garanti. Donc on va pas
construire trouver un peu de paix là
quand même. Mince.
Oui, bien sûr. Non mais il y aura de la
paix mais bien sûr. Mais construire une
centrale nucléaire c'est un appel à la
guerre en fait. c'est qu'on sait qu'il y
a un point de faiblesse donc ce sera
assez facile de créer des dégâts quoi.
Donc on arrête les barrages
hydrauliques.
Alors ben non mais les mais c'est quand
même beaucoup moins grave un barage
c'est
un barrage qui qui pète000 personnes.
Bien sûr sûr. Non mais bien sûr mais il
y a c'est c'est quand même des choses
qu'on enfin comment dire c'est c'est pas
un barrage hydraulique. Oui ça c'est
momentanément enfin instantanément c'est
beaucoup qui bug.
Ouais. Non non mais c'est c'est beaucoup
de dégâts. Mais une centrale nucléaire
qui pète, c'est un territoire enfin
c'est chez Ternobyl quoi. C'est c'est on
perd de la surface arabe. Enfin c'est
c'est quand même dramatique quoi. Et
avec un nuage qui se propage enfin si
Zaporijia
pète un jour où le vent est du mauvais
côté hein si on peut dire. Euh c'est pas
de technologie.
Oui mais enfin mais l'impact il est
quand même en B. Moi je je comprends pas
qu'on puisse aujourd'hui sérieusement
penser faire des EPR2. En plus à à une
époque c'est les centrales nucléaires
qu'on a fait dans les années 70, on
pouvait comprendre parce qu'à l'époque
les renouvelables étaient vraiment à
niveau de base quoi. C'est des petites
éoliennes de rien du tout du solaire qui
marchait pas très bien. Bon là
maintenant on a des des technologies
alors je presque dire qu'ils sont
performantes quoi. Donc ils sont haut
niveau de performance attendue et donc
ils sont nettement plus compétitives en
terme de robustesse.
Ah bah si c'est robust que c'est
distribué une tout tout ce qui est
centralisé c'est plus fragile hein. Donc
il faut que ce soit distribué pour que
ce soit robuste. il faut que ce soit
pluriel. Donc si on met tout, si on met
du nucléaire, ça veut dire qu'on va
moins développer le renouvelable et donc
on va moins en mettre et ben le jour où
on arrête une centrale nucléaire, on a
vraiment plus rien. Alors que si on a
développé des tas de d'énergie
renouvelables d'hiver, bah c'est
beaucoup plus robuste, hein. Il y a pas
photo. Alors ça pour le coup donc pour
moi c'est c'est une question
pragmatique quoi. Dans un monde
fluctuant, on ne fait pas de centrale
nucléaire, enfin on arrête d'en refaire.
On les utilise jusqu'au bout là. OK,
voilà, on les a construites à l'époque,
ça pouvait encore à peu près justifier
mais maintenant on en fait plus quoi.
Enfin, c'est faut se réveiller quoi.
C'est ça a pas l'air de prendre ce que
ce cap là.
Oui, je sais bien. Mais alors bon, ça
dépend les écos micréacteurs, les gros
réacteurs microréacteurs ils sont pas
prêts d'ailleurs, hein, les
microréacteurs mais en plus un microré
rééacteur, c'est juste une bombe sale
qu'on transporte. Enfin, je veux dire
c'est c'est enf pas forcément qu'on
transporte mais qu'on qu'on disperse
quoi. Donc c'est c'est enfin c'est moi
je ça ça m'étonne quand même que qu'on
en soit encore là. Et en fait faut sur
l'énergie en fait c'est la première
question à se poser, c'est de combien
d'énergie a-t-on besoin ? Là
aujourd'hui, si on fait des centrales
nucléaires pour alimenter des usines de
fast fassion, euh franchement quel est
l'intérêt quoi ? Euh quelle est la part
d'énergie qu'on utilise qui sert à des
choses toxiques pour l'environnement de
combien d'énergie a-t-on besoin pour que
la société vive bien sans être toxique
pour l'environ.
Est-ce que vous êtes pour le
rationnement énergétique ?
Alors, je suis pour cap l'énergie comme
on peut faire à Lyon par exemple pour
l'eau en
français. Ça donne quoi ? Capé.
Capé ? Oui, enfin qu'on met un plafond
quoi. Donc ça veut dire que bah par
exemple pour l'eau, hein, ça a été fait
dans certaines villes comme à Lyon,
c'est que les premiers litres mètres
cubes d'eau sont gratuits. Après, il y a
un tarif standard quoi et puis après
l'eau qu'on prend pour la piscine ou
pour sa 15e piscine. Alors là, c'est
très très cher. Et puis en fait, il y a
pas de 15e piscine parce queen fait,
s'il y a un plafond, on n pas le droit
de prendre plus d'eau. Ben, on pourrait
faire pareil pour l'énergie. Euh, il y a
pas de raison que on utilise autant
d'énergie. En gros, quand on a beaucoup
d'argent, au bout d'un moment, on finit
quand même par faire des choses
toxiques, quoi. C'est c'est Et donc
ouais, mettre un plafond à l'énergie, ce
serait un moyen quand même de limiter le
le délire performant. Ouis.
Oh, vous avez vous avez jamais fait
cuire une petite langouste sur le pont
de votre yach accompagné de jolies
créatures.
C'est pour ça.
Mais à la limite, alors c'est je vais
être l'avocat du diable. C'est que
pourquoi pas des yachtes mais des yautes
partagés ? Pourquoi besoin ? une galère.
Non non non à la limite bah enfin là je
force le trait. Bon ils sont construits
donc on on peut on peut les garder mais
par contre c'est pas propriétaire c'est
qu'on peut faire un voyage en y pour
voir à quoi ça ressemble.
Je suis pas du tout un avocat de Yot,
hein, on est d'accord, mais c'est juste
pour aller dans ce sens-là. Euh la
version de transition, on va dire, c'est
que sur ce, oui, on peut peut-être faire
l'expérience d'un yout
à quel point c'est débile et après on
revient, quoi. Mais
avec ou sans langouste
et pourquoi pas avec l'angouste quoi.
Mais mais c'est c'est juste pour faire
de l'éducation quoi. L'éducation au
délire quoi.
Et quand on se fait contaminer par le
délire,
oui, ben c'est justement alors quand on
se fait contaminer par le délire, ça
marche tant qu'il y a abondance de
ressources. quand il y a plus de
ressources en fait ça sera en fait ça va
être rapidement devenir ringar. C'est
qu'en fait il y a déjà du fly shaming.
Donc ça c'est pour ceux qui prennent des
avions. Voilà la honte de prendre
l'avion. Euh le SUV, il y a aussi du SUV
shaming, la honte d'avoir un SUV. Donc
de plus en plus les ultra performants
vont être très ringard. Moi, je j'arrête
pas de dire de ringardiser la
performance parce que c'est le monde
d'avant, le monde obsolète et donc ça va
pas du tout faire rêver. En fait, c'est
faut bien comprendre que ça va
rapidement devenir assez Tesla par
exemple. Voilà les voitures Tesla quand
on a compris que la batterie est soudée
au châssis pour optimiser he donc cette
batterie là qui est énorme, la voiture
fait 2 tonnes, mais vu qu'elle est
soudée au châssis, si une voiture Tesla
se fait inonder juste le rat du châssis
hein, c'est une voiture qui devient
jetable. Elle part à la casse. Vous
vous rappelez ce qu'avait dit le le
l'américain responsable de la sécurité
dans un village plein d'inondation et a
dit "Sortez vos voitures électriques
parce que ça risque de [__] le feu
partout."
Et en plus voilà, c'est ça. Donc en
fait, c'est c'est des risques mais même
enfin, je veux dire pour un un acquéreur
de voiture de savoir que sa voiture est
jetable s'il y a 20 cm d'eau dans son
garage, bah pourquoi on va encore
acheter des Tesla ? Et alors Tesla c'est
pratique parce que le logo de Tesla
c'est un stérilet en fait. Donc même
c'est un stérilé.
Ah vous êtes horrible. Ben oui, mais
c'est ça. Donc
d'ailleurs le stérilet, c'est important.
Dans le monde où on se dirige, est-ce
qu'il faudra vraiment euh encadrer les
naissances ? Vo
alors euh je pense pas hein. Il y a pas
besoin. On le voit d'ailleurs avec la
Chine hein. Euh la la Chine a plus
l'enfant unique et bah en fait il c'est
la démographie baisse pour des raisons
économiques. Enfin les gens sont pas
idiots quand même hein. Ils voi bien que
c'est en train de bouger là. Donc ça
pour le dire très froidement, c'est trop
cher quoi.
Avoir un gamin.
Ouais.
Bah c'est ce qui se passe en Chine hein.
Je c'est pas c'est c'est démograph mais
oui mais c'est un peu partout. C'est
pour ça que ça b c'est pas parce que il
y a eu des grandes guerres ou parce
qu'il y a des épidémies, c'est pour des
raisons économiques. C'est ça la raison
principale hein. Enfin je suis pas
démographe mais c'est ce que j'ai lu en
tout cas.
Est-ce queil y a un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avec nous qu'on a
oublié ? Euh bah peut-être revenir sur
la recarbonation de l'économie quand
même parce que je l'ai dit peut-être
trop rapidement tout à l'heure et je me
suis dit que je fallait que je revienne
dessus.
Je vous pose juste avant de commencer
une question internet qui avait l'air
intéressante. Fait-il une différence
entre robustesse et gestion de risque ?
Alors oui, parce que la gestion du
risque c'est quelque chose que en fait
c'est très arrogant en fait. La la
gestion du risque, ça veut dire qu'on
sait tous les risques si on fait de la
gestion du risque et donc les
entreprises par exemple font de la
gestion du risque depuis des décennies
he mais sauf que c'est du risque
économique.
Maintenant, il va falloir étendre le
risque au risque social, au risque
géopolitique et au risque écologique.
Donc du coup, c'est très clair, on n'est
pas capable de savoir le niveau de
risque. Donc ça veut dire que dans un
monde qui de dans un monde stable,
abondant ressources, on pouvait prévoir,
on pouvait faire de la gestion de
risque. dans un monde fluctuant en
pénorie chronique de ressources, on ne
prévoit pas, on se prépare. Donc ça
c'est très militaire d'ailleurs c'est
plutôt donc en fait on se prépare, ça
veut dire qu'on diversifie, qu'on
explore différentes voies quoi. Donc
c'est de la gestion de risque si on veut
mais c'est vraiment différent. Ça c'est
plus c'est plus vraiment de la gestion,
c'est plutôt de l'exploration quoi.
On peut être fier de notre armée parce
que c'est une armée robuste.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que Comment vous vous
modélisez les l'émergence de conflit ?
Alors, je la modélise pas trop, hein.
Moi, je suis pas un modélisateur de de
conflit, mais il y a
voilà, je là, je suis vraiment juste un
citoyen quoi qui observe euh et bah ce
qu'on voit, c'est qu'il y a des liens
aux ressources à peu près à chaque fois,
soit l'abondance, soit la pénurie, hein,
ça peut être pour différentes raisons,
euh des idéologies, du pouvoir. En fait,
quand quand on voit ceux qui sont à la
manœuvre, hein, pour les conflits là,
c'est souvent des vieux hommes ultra
riches névrosés, quoi.
C'est quand même le profil, hein. Donc
en fait c'est plutôt des gens
Ouais. Alors bien sûr mais ça c'est
parce que la démocratie s'est fait
dévoyer aussi. La démocratie autoritaire
elle peut être autoritaire une
démocratie he 493 c'est un ingrédient de
démocratie autoritaire. Donc en fait bah
c'est c'est
c'est performant
c'est ça. Ouais c'est performant dans la
joie.
Oui mais alors mais Johan Chapout le dit
mieux que moi hein. Le 493 c'est le même
article que l'article 482 de la
République de Vaimar qui a été conçu
justement pour ça pour être plus
performant. Et donc bah la performance
appelle la violence.
Question internet. Le Bitcoin peut-il
être considéré comme un facteur de
robustesse ?
Ben je crois pas. C'est un peu comme
l'A. C'est qu'un bit
luiême n'étant pas centralisé peut-il
être considéré comme une monnaie
intrinsèque robuste ?
Voil exactement. Alors le Bitcoin, son
architecture est robuste parce qu'elle
est décentralisée et cetera, mais elle
est en fait c'est une robustesse juste à
son échelle de son architecture. La
façon la le miner le Bitcoin, toutes les
l'industrie que ça alimente, ça c'est de
la performance hein. C'est des mafias,
c'est
Oh, c'est pas des mafias, il y a
beaucoup de choses derrière quand même.
Donc du coup, c'est c'est la robustesse,
elle est forcément multi-échelle. C'est
que fait, on ne peut pas être robuste à
un niveau et être performant ailleur. Il
faut être robuste du début à la fin.
Donc ça veut dire qu'il faut être ancré
jusqu'au territoire. Faut être robuste
avec ses liens à l'eau, à ses aliments,
à ses fournitures, au services et
cetera. Ça peut pas être prendre cette
tournure là. Non, je sais pas vous avez
remarqué, c'est en train de prendre
cette tournure là.
Ouais. Pour
en terme de robustesse aller jusque dans
la racine du territoire. Ouais, bien
sûr. Mais ça c'est le justement c'est un
un signal hein, c'est qu'en fait bah
quand les les communes commencent à
diversifier les sources d'énergie ou
d'électricité, c'est une forme de
robustesse territoriale quoi.
Une dernière question internet avant de
reparler de la la recarbonation de
l'économie. Euh
bonjour Olivier Amand. Que pensez-vous
de l'agriculture de conservation des
sols et de leur diverses techniques
semi-suscouvert par exemple. Est-ce
qu'une alter est-ce une alternative
réaliste pour sortir de nos années de
labour ?
Ouais. Alors ben alors donc c'est là
c'est une un peu compliqué parce que
pour conserver les sols en effet faut
faut pas labourer. On le sait hein,
quand on labour on détruit des
écosystèmes. D'ailleurs, ça y met
beaucoup de CO2, la matière organique se
se disperse donc c'est très toxique.
Mais bon, quand on ne labour plus,
surtout quand on a labouré pendant des
années, en fait, on a sélectionné des
plantes invasives. Donc quand on labour
plus, c'est plutôt les plantes invasives
qui viennent. Donc les adventistes, on
peut appeler ça des plantes pionaires
aussi hein, mais c'est parce qu'on a on
a fait un désert. Donc du coup, bah ce
qui vient, c'est les plantes pionnières.
Donc du coup, c'est un peu compliqué.
Mais alors par contre sur le sol, moi
c'est ce que je dis souvent sur le bilan
carbone, si je devais réinventer le
bilan carbone parce qu'aujourd'hui un
bilan carbone c'est le CO2 éI hein donc
qui est un peu aberrant. Un vrai bilan
carbone ce serait de faire des carottes
dans le sol et de mesurer la quantité de
matière organique dans les sols.
C'est pas les les bourguignons qui font
ça ?
Ouais par exemple. Ouais. Voilà. Mais en
fait si on mesure la quantité de matière
organique dans le sol en fait s'il y a
beaucoup de matière organique ça veut
dire qu'il y a de la biomasse qui pousse
au-dessus. Donc il y a de la
biodiversité il y a pas trop de
pollution parce qu'il y a de la vie. euh
il y a du carbone qui est stocké donc
c'est positif pour le climat et s'il y a
beaucoup de matières organique, c'est
autant de ressources pour les des
biomatériaux quoi, euh qui sont
disponibles. Donc en fait euh les
paysans par exemple plutôt que de leur
faire remplir des tableaux Excel euh
pour voir euh s'ils ont bien rempli les
règles de lieu et cetera, je ferai juste
des carottes dans leur sol. S'il y a
plein de matière organique, je laisse
tranquille quoi. Par contre, s'ils sont
en train de faire un désert, c'est qu'il
y a de moins en moins de matière
organique. Alors là, là on discute quoi.
Et donc, on peut faire en effet
conservation des sols mais plein
d'autres techniques hein. Enfin, il y a
là pour le coup, on a toute une zoologie
de solution quand même.
La recarbonation de l'économie. Ben
voilà, ça fait une belle transition
parce que la recarbonation de de
l'économie en fait quand on dit
décarboner l'économie en fait ça n'a
aucun sens hein. Et Aurore Stéphan sur
ce plateau dirait la même chose. C'est
quand on décarbone l'économie en fait on
est en train de remplacer le pétrole par
des métaux et donc en fait c'est on est
en train de remplacer une pollution par
une autre qui est au moins aussi toxique
hein. Fa déverser de l'arsenique des
métaux lourds parce qu'on fait des mines
et cetera. Bah c'est valet de l'arsenque
à carcasson à côté du mine d'or quoi.
Voilà par exemple. Donc en fait, il faut
pas décarboner l'économie, il faut
décombustionner l'économie. Il faut
arrêter de brûler du carbone. Faut
arrêter de brûler du bois, du charbon,
du pétrole, des biocarburants, tout ça.
Enfin, en tout cas, faut réduire
fortement. Mais par contre, il faut
surtout pas décarboner l'économie, il
faut recarboner l'économie. Il faut
remplacer le pétrole et les métaux par
des molécules biosourcées et
biodégradables. Et alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que on a déjà plein
de solutions quand même hein. On sait
faire des peintures biourcées, on sait
faire des batteries à base de ligine he
qui est une molécule du bois abondante
dont on fait rien actuellementin. Alors
bien sûr tout de suite je vais le dire,
on va pas faire des forêts pour faire
des batteries. Il y a un ordre he là
c'est plutôt juridique. Question de
droit. Euh quand on fait pousser de la
biomasse, donc des feuilles, des
racines, des tiges, des graines, tout
ça, le premier rôle de cette biomasse,
c'est qu'elle doit nourrir les service
écosystémique. Ça c'est le numéro 1. Le
numéro 2, c'est les aliments pour
l'humanité. Et le numéro 3, c'est les
biomatériaux. Et donc en fait, les
biomatériaux qu'on va construire, quand
on va recarboner l'économie, on va
plutôt le faire avec des déchets
organiques. Euh un exemple, je vais
prendre l'exemple de mon labo. On a une
collaboration avec Thomas Deou, un
physicien à Lyon. Euh bah Thomas, ils
ont trouvé dans leur équipe que quand on
prend un oignon, donc si vous ouvrez un
oignon, dedans, il y a une petite
membrane, ça c'est un épiderme. Bah
cette épiderme, vous le faites sécher,
vous le mettez dans un microscope un peu
particulier et vous allez voir que cet
épiderme d'oignon séché a des propriétés
phononiques. Donc phononique, ça veut
dire que ça absorbe certaines zesdes
acoustiques dans le gaherz. Alors, je
vous la fais courte, mais dans vos
téléphones portables, il y a des terres
rares dont la fonction c'est de faire
ça. Et donc, c'est ça l'avenir, c'est de
remplacer le pétrole et les métaux et
les minéraux rares par ces molécules ou
ces architectures biosourcées
biodégradable. C'est ça. Recarboner
l'économie. Et il y a plein de choses,
hein. Euh le stocker les données
numériques dans l'ADN, enfin il y a il y
a vraiment donc c'est tout n'est pas
prêt hein. C'est il y a encore du chemin
à faire mais on va aller vers ça. Il y
aura pas le choix hein. Euh notre seule
ressource massive et renouvelable sur
Terre c'est les plantes hein. La planète
est bleue mais le monde est vert hein.
Donc c'est là-dedans qu'on va euh qu'on
va creuser quoi. Et donc toujours pareil
he en commençant par préserver les
services écosystémiques, hein, la
biodiversité d'abord, ensuite les
aliments pour les humains et en troisème
les biomatériaux.
Euh il y a il y a plein de questions
internet.
La baisse de la fécondité n'est-elle pas
plutôt habituellement associée à une
amélioration du niveau de vie ?
Oui, bien sûr, c'est de l'éducation en
fait hein. Quand on enfin alors jeis pas
faire mais mais en fait en effet quand
on a améliore son son niveau de vie et
qu'on on se projette dans le monde futur
pour ses enfants, on se dit bah tiens
oui en fait là je me dis que bah si je
fais moins d'enfant, il a plus de chance
d'avoir une meilleure vie aussi parce
que quand on il y a moins de mortalité
infantile aussi enfin tout bêtement.
Donc tout ça se parle évidemment.
Est-ce que vous prenez la décroissance ?
Alors la décroissance en fait c'est
alors c'est on est assez aligné en fait
mais c'est très ça braque he la
décroissance he pour en parler
différents secteurs. En fait quand on
parle de décroissance person il y a des
gens qui écoutent plus après alors la
décroissance en fait c'est une période
de transition entre la période de
croissance dans laquelle on est en train
de terminer là et la période de
post-croissance. Donc la décroissance,
c'est cette transition he Timothé Paris
que ralentir au périr. Ben en fait cette
décroissance euh ce qui est très bien
là-dedans, c'est qu'en fait c'est une
donnée. On est en train de basculer,
donc il va falloir changer de ce modèle
croissant croissance du PIB qui n'a
aucun sens hein. Quand il y a un
mégafeu, hein, les pompiers qui vont au
mégafeu en consommant du pétrole, ils
font monter le PIB, donc ils font de la
croissance. Enf c'est là qu'on voit que
c'est quand même la drogue, tout ça ça
voilà, tout ça, ça fait de la
croissance. Donc du coup, bah la
décroissance, donc ça c'est très positif
dans le sens où c'est euh un regard
réaliste sur le monde qui vient, mais
c'est un mot négatif. La décroissance en
fait, on peut mal le comprendre comme de
la récession et du coup comme la
nécessité de réduire. Ça c'est pas une
pulsion humaine profonde donc ça va pas
mobiliser. Ce qui mobilise c'est une
pulsion humaine profonde comme le besoin
de reconnaissance, la s'alimenter enfin
tout ça quoi. Donc du coup ben la
robustesse,
travaillez votre ego mon ami hein.
Oui mais la la robustesse c'est une
pulsion humaine profonde. C'est la le
besoin et l'envie de durer et de
transmettre. En fait
ces gènes,
c'est
ces gênes
transmettre ses gênes.
Alors ou c'est savoir c'est ça peut être
culturel. C'est juste ça voilà des
expériences de vie quoi. Quand on est
enseignant, on transmet hein, c'est pas
forcément génétique quoi. Mais mais
c'est c'est la robustesse en fait. C'est
ça qui est génial, c'est que ça enfin
pour moi en tout cas c'est que c'est
c'est pragmatique dans un monde
fluctuant et c'est il y a pas que moi
qu'on parle d'orbusess he c'est c'est ça
fait très longtemps qu'on en parle.
C'est c'est quelque chose de pragmatique
dans un monde fluctuant. Ça répond à une
pulsion humaine profonde et c'est mieux
ça génère de la sobriété. c'est qu'en
fait plutôt que de commencer par la
sobriété qui peut justement braquer
parce que c'est réduire et du coup ça va
pas mobiliser tout le monde et les
pauvres on va pas leur demander d'être
sobre si on commence par la robustesse
ben voilà ils sont déjà sobres donc on
va commencer par la robustesse. Donc ça
ça parle à tout le monde c'est universel
et ce que ça fait c'est que ça génère de
la sobriété. Le le tout réparable c'est
l'exemple parfait. Si on veut faire des
objets réparables, ils ne se sont pas
sobres. Il y a des gros boulons, ils
sont plus gros, ils consomment plus de
ressources donc ils sont pas sobres.
Mais vu qu'ils sont réparables, ils vont
durer plus longtemps. On va les
transmettre et ça génère de la sobriété.
Donc faut commencer par le objet. C'est
toujours pareil hein, c'est une méthode
quoi. Premier critère de tri.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Ouais. Oh bah ouais. Euh alors bon alors
le rapport mesdoses hein évidemment
limite à la croissance mais ça je pense
qu'il a déjà été conseillé un certain
nombre de fois. Euh au mot confort de
Stéphane Bonnie euh qui décrit très bien
le fait que vu qu'on a choisi le confort
en fait on s'est désensualisé. Notre
relation monde se fait par des boutons
poussoirs et des écrans. Donc en fait on
on ne supporte plus certaines odeurs, on
ne supporte plus qu'on se fasse toucher.
Voilà, enfin c'est on a un rapport au
monde qui est de la distance, on devient
hermétique, hein, comme Iron Man quoi.
On se on se blinde quoi. Donc très
stérile, on se transforme en machine
quoi. Donc voilà, Stéphane Boniff. Les
autistes ne sont pas des machines.
Ah non, bien sûr. Oui. Non mais je
parlais d'automatisme, hein.
D'automatisme. Oui. Voilà. De Iron Man,
c'est plutôt Oui, c'est parce que c'est
Oui, mais là c'est plutôt le
l'équipement, quoi. C'est pas forcément
la personne, c'est Oui, on est d'accord.
C'est plutôt le l'équipement. Un autre
bouquin, Rendre le monde disponible de
Artmosa. C'est un très beau bouquin
parce qu'en fait Artm Rosa, il a écrit
accélération avant où c'était plutôt un
constat d'un monde en accélération sans
chercher vraiment les causes. Donc moi,
je mettrais plutôt la performance hein
dans l'accélération. Et euh mais par
contre, il a trouvé une sorte de
solution dans le sens quand tout à
l'heure je disais que quand on manque de
temps, il faut se reconnecter à son
espace et ben rendre le monde
indisponible c'est exactement ça. C'est
en fait euh prendre le temps de se
connecter à son espace, de sentir les
vibrations de les aspirités du monde. Et
en fait quand on fait ça, euh on
ralentit mais sans s'en rendre compte.
C'est juste qu'on veut plus interagir
quoi. Bah quand on fait ça, c'est
toujours plus vertueux, c'est plus
robuste et cetera quoi.
Vous connaissez le proverbe égyptien ?
Un homme pressé est un homme déjà mort.
Oui. Ben voilà.
Il y a autre chose dans le genre alors
c'est peut-être pas égyptien mais c'est
la première chose qui qui meurt à la
guerre c'est le plan de bataille.
Donc c'est ça se parle un peu. C'estàd
que dans un monde fluctuant on va
arrêter de prévoir quoi. On va se
préparer quoi.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Alors pour les jeunes générations et ben
justement euh ce qui sont souvent dans
l'écoanxiété hein et je pense qu'il y en
a beaucoup là qui qui nous écoutent euh
c'est vraiment de considérer de prendre
le monde tel qu'il vient. C'estàd que
euh là, je vais être vraiment bêtement
scientifique. Le monde va fluctuer. Ça
c'est une donnée euh inéluctable. Ça va
tanguer. On va on quitte le monde de la
moyenne pour rentrer dans le monde de
l'écart-ype. Dans ce monde-là, on peut
choisir de rester dans le monde d'avant
suicidaire. La voix étroite dans un
monde qui change tout le temps, ça
marche pas. On se canalise, ça marche
pas. Si on choisit le voix de la voix de
la robustesse hein, pour le dire
rapidement, on peut mettre d'autres
mots, hein. La voix de la viabilité, de
l'adaptabilité, enfin voilà, d'autres
mots, mais un parcours plutôt divers
quoi. Alors, c'est plus joyeux parce
qu'on a plus d'interaction, on passe la
période de turbulence notamment de la
transition là et en plus on construit le
monde de demain. Donc, en fait, on sait
que les enjeux sont là et le sens de son
activité tous les jours, elle est au
même niveau quoi. Donc en fait, tous les
jours, on sait pourquoi on se lève,
quoi. Moi, c'est pour ça que j'ai le
plutôt le sourire, hein, c'est qu'en
fait je rencontre beaucoup de collectifs
justement qui sont au marge et qui sont
en train de construire le monde de
demain. Et en fait, c'est euh il faut
quand même, c'est la fameuse phrase
hein, un arbre qui tombe fait plus de
bruit qu'une forêt qui pousse. Euh, dans
les médias, on entend beaucoup les
arbres tomber mais il y a la forêt qui
pousse et donc faut passer du temps avec
la forêt qui pousse, quoi. C'est ça que
je dirais au jotes, quoi.
Telle est la voix.
La troisème voix.
Olivier Amand merci
merci Merci.
[Musique]